what they don't tell you is the
instruction manual for the pinatas that
when you put juicy erotic beaded there
it starts to warp the cardboard it
starts to leak in the car the the the
unicorn cow's belly started to really
sleep we're like we need to get this
thing's gonna blow right more tape
though way outside of seal yeah - like
seal it in when we walked in the first
people we saw were like 48 year old
civilians and I turned our neon go this
is a bad idea
this idea just got way better
welcome to Ari Shaffir skeptic tank I'm
your host Ari Shaffir
hi everybody on today's episode what's
going on
number 300 I have Danish you know Neil
how your 50 the boys are back for the
best I've had I'm on every 50 since I
think episode 100 some of the best ones
where that means zero I'm 100 150 200
250 300 is the fifth time on the best
ones word or guys when you talk about
being in door delivery stuff I actually
suggested oh I met these Canadian girls
in a bag on Myanmar and uh and I
suggested they were like oh you have a
podcast so I wonder how many here one of
the girls got her name from van
I want to hear so I was like all right
well I usually tell people to to check
out episode 100 with Danish no Neil
that's that's what I said it was like I
know that was a good one I know I
remember that make me laugh really hard
when I was uh I was recording it and
then also when I was like listening to
it it's a fun like a teaser and I saw
her like two days later she goes Ari I
just I couldn't this is like a 19 year
old like good girl she I couldn't I
couldn't with with in like no time you
were we were talking about having sex
with [__] people and something else
horrible - I don't know what it was so I
don't I don't know I don't remember that
episode anymore I don't remember that
happening at all but they're on every 50
so we had to figure out what we're gonna
talk about for this one and because of
the topic based podcast you know how it
is you listen so O'Neill camera within a
good idea why don't we talk about I'll
compare Hollywood the struggle to like
make it making it being like making a
living in that business
it's hard it's hard for sure nope nobody
has questions about that but you can be
poor for a while and then at some point
you just can't be poor anymore or you
cannot get success for a while and then
at some point you just can't deal with
not having successes anymore like how
long are you gonna believe in yourself
before going well no one else does
so maybe I'm wrong it's hard and
sometimes you just need a break here
there I compared it to it to a to a NFL
receiver catching a pass near the
sidelines and he's just gonna get to be
in zone he's got about 12 yards left to
get to the end zone but he's falling out
of bounds and that's what it's like and
stand up where you're sort of you feel
yourself falling out of bounds but if
you can just get to that goal if you can
just get someone to book you on a TV
show or or or get booked on a live show
that's really good or something get on
new faces at Montreal or I don't know
something get it start to headline
offers then you can score your you've
got a goal you know you've got a
touchdown and then and then it can keep
it going so the game's not over but if
it's if it's fourth and goal from from
the [__] you know with time running
out and you're dancing on the sideline
if you fall out of bounds you're done
but if you can just stay even a first
down if you can just stay in dancing
staying in bounds and so you get that
first down you can stay in the game you
know you haven't turned the ball over on
downs and a lot of comics they turn the
ball over on downs they were talented
they're real talented and they just
[__] [__] didn't work out for him and
they just couldn't do it anymore
and they failed out maybe they had a
girlfriend or wife saying I need you to
pay the bills get a real job maybe they
had a kid and they had felt that [__]
pressure to support that baby
so anyway
Danish and O'Neill while there why
wildly talented and they're great
writers in the great podcast guess I
mean ask Bert Kreischer you got to go
and listen one of Bert Kreischer
episodes with them or any of mine I
don't even have been on Rogen's episodes
it seems like a an oversight for sure I
hate right they'd be [__] perfect on
that the big MMA fans O'Neill loves cars
and not so hard to bear by ant they're
so out there as long as I didn't get
this serious as long as Rogen would let
them go like let them go nuts anyway
we start talking about when it's time to
[__] hang up the cleats when it's
time to just go I can't do this anymore
because they're thinking about it I know
they're thinking about it and they're
mid-30s you know it's just not working
out so he met at my Airbnb while I was
in Los Angeles in June and I'm we
recorder won we got weird in the middle
and went out and used the fire pit
I made smores fun episode as always
there they seemed way too skittish
around some of the stuff that I bring
out I mean you'll see pretty early on
he's before we went out and got some
ores especially O'Neill what a [__]
[__] you are man
just handle my [__] man and on my [__]
so to speak you guys are gonna love it
hey guys are gonna love this episode I
went to [__] rancid and and what's it
called yesterday
Oh a couple dates to announce oh I gotta
tell you about this show oh my god okay
first I'll just tell you about the show
September 13th in Los Angeles Los
Angeles you guys I'm doing a
storytelling show
Ari Shaffir is renamed storytelling show
at The Comedy Store in the main room I'm
not telling the lineup
I don't do lineups anymore I do surprise
lineups that's how I'm doing it from now
on my shows are gonna sell out and I
guarantee you I'm always putting on a
good show the best show I can put on you
will have a good
some names you'll recognize other people
you won't and they're gonna [__] Wow
you with how good they are and then here
there you're gonna get something doesn't
try and [__] was bad but the shows
are always gonna be worth it you're
gonna have a great time no matter what
so Ari Shaffir storytelling show are we
sure was renamed storytelling show
excuse me September 13th at the main
room get tickets at Ari Shaffir calm
also we've got an all things comedy um
what are the great re the great calm
that's four tickets Walt's loading up
there was another date oh okay I got
another rename storytelling show on
August 21st at [__] the Comedy Cellar
The Village Underground excuse me but I
think you're too late I think it's
already sold out let me tell you about
this [__] show so get tickets to that
I'm also the Impractical Jokers tour but
that's not until November but uh
September 13th don't miss it let me tell
you about this [__] show that me and
Joe Joe Louis and Jason Kander put on
last week we called it PS 1 or 9 show it
was just a converted used to be uh I
told you guys would be cool for those of
you went we had 100 tickets they were
all sold 70 people showed up so of the
30 people who bought tickets in a show
up let me tell you what you missed we
put on a show in the basement of this
weird artist colony apartment it was a
converted yeah if converted school and
all these artists live there that's like
50,000 applicants for like 100 a few
hundred spots
it's gorgeous apartment building and
downstairs we just rented out the bottom
rumpus room I called it on our Friday
Soto and um when I was killing them it
at foosball we had a foosball table in
the belly room for a while and me and
Sebastian Maz Jobrani and Juan Carlos
the fix-it guy we were the best and
everybody else hailed a comparison to us
Maz was the first one to come up with
bumper shots hitting him sideways into
the Gulf [__] those air was man
they're crooked people and uh and anyway
I was crushing Freddy Soto and toying
with him and he's extraordinary oh oh
I'm sorry I couldn't have experienced
playing
foosball table the title bombers rumpus
room and the rumpus room so he did this
show downstairs at a rumpus room the
crowd knew who it was me Joel is chasing
Cantor the rest of the lineup surprised
I always surprise you like I say
Ari Shaffir puts on good shows you can
guarantee that Jill this hosted I
brought him on and then he hosts it
brought up Jason Cantor and Julis got
back on brought on Greg Fitzsimmons the
crowd went [__] nuts for the 30
people about taking us in show up you
must correct for Simmons on a [__]
Monday night in the Upper East Side
where there's no comedy then he finished
killed it killed it I did his podcast
this week I don't know when they'll be
out then he brings on Dave Attell
[__] working out joke he did the
first three minutes just [__] on the
room which was great then um then did
about seven eight minutes of new jokes
working out in front of a cool crowd
what a good crowd - we had beers for
sale we had [__] cans of [__]
beers some wine from a box what a great
fun night David tell finished Jill this
goes back on brings on louis c.k
I'd admit on stage and he's at five
months but I think it's three and a half
months since he hosed the song I alive
was the last time we went on stage she
took off there's a longest amount of
time he ever took off stand up this is
first set back way to miss it [__] faces
you 30 the ones who were there you got a
great show and nobody took out their
phones you know but he picked at the
phones and start trying to record it
everyone just got lost in the moment and
had a great time as Louis came back
tried some new jokes right off a
notebook did some fun [__] in the crowd
handing out pieces of paper or [__]
having fun games man killed it [__]
ten twelve fifteen minutes that he
finished big Jay oakerson went on
destroyed probably set of the night
d-stroid and then I went on to close it
out and that's a show you got
when I just told you it's gonna be a
good show and there's 70 people who
showed up with the tickets they bought
you [__] nailed it the 30 people who
didn't you should [__] kill yourself
for missing that show that was the best
show in the world last Monday night that
was the best show in the world 20 bucks
in a [__] basement of a goddamn
rumpus room of a old converted public
school on the Upper East Side
so get tickets to my renamed
storytelling show so anyway I went to
see rancid I mean on September 13th in
the belly unmanned room of Los Angeles
tickets had already great calm was I
gonna say oh I went to rancid and
dropkick murphys yesterday me
Turner sparks from that uh from that
podcast uh well he's gonna brought me to
China but um lost in America podcast he
had tickets he an extra ticket I would
[__] it didn't have spots let's go our
tickets were so far back and Turner
right away goes no let's move down let's
not settle on this so we start going
down further further we could keep that
of a seat let's go further down then
we're pretty close somebody else comes
but we're OK there's a big giant pit
area this is in Coney Island it's a big
giant pit area and then there's a fence
behind that you can't go into there you
need some sort of we're looking so we're
sitting in the front row of the seating
area until somebody comes like I think
these are our seats monk of course they
are we just leave you just leave you've
seen someone else eat you just leave no
I'm gonna make a mess no problem go by
pick up your [__] and go one time I was
eating sunflower seeds of the UFC and I
was making a [__] mess around me and
these people came said but there's our
seats and like no there are seats and we
looked like oh we're in the wrong row
sorry and I what we went back a rope and
they just had that [__] pile of
sunflower seed shells at their feet the
ice was [__] [__] on me so anyway
we're looking though we're in these at
Coney Island and the amphitheater there
and we're looking Walla while bouncing
Souls is on stage we're looking for a
way in and we scope it out we can get
past this one security guard down to the
entrance of where we go in and I try to
get past so there's one ladies looking
for four make sure your beers in a cup
and not in a not in a can and another
dude that's black dude white lady black
dude with
bread's he's looking for wristbands but
he's barely looking he's very looking I
don't want it doing on the right side on
the left side that's what they got going
on so this [__] big [__] Latino
guys is talking to the lady the black
guys distracted I'm trying to sneak past
him to get into the pit area and the
[__] big Latino guy [__] shifts
and move and shoves me up against the
goddamn railing by accident and I keep
trying to shove in and move in he keeps
[__] budding meats
[__] fat ass literally this fat ass
shoving me up against his [__]
fencing and I can't get past him and now
there's a [__] commotion and the
black dude sees is okay cuz he IRISA and
I show no no no it's got every red
wristband like where do I get that I
love when you act all [__] you know
what you're doing something wrong you
still act like you didn't do anything so
I go okay go back out there guys like
they come they come Turner and his buddy
Chris they're like what happened to come
get him we need a red wristband like
[__] we're looking at it and then Turner
and Chris they try to go they try to go
and they get stopped
well they waited for a distraction while
the black guys check in somebody's
wristband they went to his little to
their left towards where the ladies and
they go oh no she goes you know you need
to put these beer cans in cups and she
hands out cups and she then she goes oh
you guys gotta have a red wristband you
can't come in here that way oh my god
okay they come back out you don't make a
big commotion when you're getting caught
and bounced out don't make a big
commotion because you don't want them
recognizing your face now on the other
side when you have gotten into a place
you're not supposed to be in - on your
way out to go to the bathroom you do
make a big commotion
so we tried one of those I went past one
in the first security guard and I was
like I went back I was like hey where's
where's the bat I knew where the
bathroom was so where's the bathroom and
he's like pointed it's right there and
that was like and I look back I'm sorry
man
I'm a [__] idiot huh it's like it was
right in front of me because I know man
I do the same [__] like that's crazy all
right you saw my face I saw your my face
I saw yours that's how you do it then
when you come back like hey buddy you
walked right past me no check again
they've already seen you they recognize
your face keep in mind when I was a door
guy at the Comedy Store the way I would
check your age is I would look at the
year on your license and that's it if it
was before the date that had to be then
I look at you know if was on that here I
look at the the
from the day but it was like let's say
like what's now 2017 that means cut off
his 1996 to be 21 no yeah so if I saw in
1995 or before I would give it back if I
saw 97 or later you're not getting in if
I saw 96 I would like wait let me see
the the month August or its yeah we're
good you know it you could be a white
dude and hand me a black lady's ID and I
wouldn't even see that the picture I'm
just looking for the date that's these
people working security
they're just dudes they're just people
like you and me they don't really give a
[__] except occasional people ever get a
hard-on so we can't get in there it's
real like what are we gonna do how do we
get in
like the [__] there's got to be a way
for a distraction maybe we're gonna wait
until [__] Dropkick Murphys go on
dropkick murphys and then when
everyone's going in but they held
everybody it was [__] wouldn't work
we need something red we needed a red
wristband I'm like I don't know reaching
in my pocket I had a thing of wet naps
that I pulled right when I left the
apartment I pulled a thing of wet naps
maybe my swamp my ass will get swampy
and I'll need him so we tore him into
strips
he's part of a wet naps thing I tore him
into strips they were red and we each
have them for our wrists but how are we
gonna tie it first of all they weren't
quite long enough so you had to like
they could if you tie them tight around
your wrists they could just overlap but
then you had a help you know how to hold
them with your other hand call too much
attention to it and then Turner goes we
need some gum I have gum so he went to
the bathroom we got a Cubs for our beer
so we wouldn't call attention for call
her attention went to the bathroom
chewed a half a stick of gum each we use
gum to seal the red newly-formed
wristbands and then we were off to the
races so Chris goes in first he has I
found the best the best stance for it
cup up high in your left hand passing by
the left lady right hand with the
wristband headed in his pocket so he's
just sticking out of his pocket he
didn't wait he's went for it the black
the lady looked for the cup could the
black dude glanced down at his wrist saw
red clamps back up with the next person
and I was like [__] yeah I took my hand
moves right down because I was gonna
hold hold it up with the cup and then
she would have looked at both went down
the guy told me that I felt some tapping
in my shoulder I went through it was in
the pit felt tapping I was ignoring it
no no tapping harder harder tapping I'm
not turning around
and then eventually was [__] Turner
who was right behind me we got in $20
tickets we went [__] set our $40
tickets we got a [__] $115 pit
tickets with ingenuity American
ingenuity and then we made a mistake and
went out to pee try to come back and
they were like way harsh Shana on the
way out I went out to be in ladies let
me see your wrist like why I'm leaving
just let me see your wrist and it looks
because you're not getting back in this
way and I just kept walking didn't let
her see my face so they went on the
other way that wasn't working what's a
Pickers brand you need a block a red one
oh we were good and then came back in
she got distracted right in back in
again the pit for dropkick was great the
pit for rancid was great man nonviolent
pit ever sweaty twenty people sweat on
me
they killed I didn't know how many of
the songs that would know but I knew
like the whole that whole album out come
the wolves I had that I knew they played
all those they didn't leave anything on
the table
[__] killer show what does it have to
do with this episode nothing right
alright you guys a start I will tell you
that I thought of quitting a bunch of
times but we'll get into that maybe in
the outro let's start the episode Danish
Turner O'Neill you guys got to get there
but their podcast the Danish and O'Neill
podcast subscribe to it immediately
check them out on everything else but
definitely subscribe to the Danish
Gnomeo podcast there's no guests just
craziness it's called Danish and O'Neill
their videos are amazing they're just
they're just hilarious guys they're just
hilarious guys but
a great podcast everything I do is good
you should check it out Danish attorney
I'll subscribe just charter right now
thank you for continuing to watch my
special by the way double negative those
of you who haven't watched it I know
you're going to those of you watch the
first half I know you're gonna get to
the second half it's it's great you guys
are gonna love it and by the way what I
do love about the energy meals that they
do anything so I think it's kind of
shitty I'll just say this that I did a
podcast O'Neill's dad passed away and to
help them last year a year ago I did a
podcast with with the Danish for Danish
to nail podcast and Danish refuses to
air it and I think it's [__] and I
think you should let them know I think
you should let them know what are they
on Twitter the Danish and O'Neill Danish
and O'Neill twitter.com slash Danish
Danish Danish and O'Neill yeah oh and E
oh let's see if that works one at a
chance yes it works let him know that
[__] either they [__] censor people's
podcasts I don't think it's fair at all
I would love diffident to release that
but until they do I mean you know I go
on to try to promote my stuff I do you
the favor ask him I won't release it I
think it's totally unfair so ladies and
gentlemen Ari Shaffir skeptic I probably
present Ari Shaffir skeptic tank episode
[Music]
[Applause]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
you've gotten way too comfortable with
it I have gotten too comfortable with it
yeah we're talking about [__] play I
thought you were gonna throw handfuls of
[__] at me when you took a dump in
Griffith Park that's why I was throwing
stuff at you here all right as like a
defensive mode yeah it was more of like
him to offer an early offensive you're
reverting back to chimpanzees status on
me in Joshua Tree what I should wait
tried to it tried to whip your [__] with
a stick wait well you were just
listening in the [__] middle of the
trail your pants are down around your
ankles
oh yeah walking yeah yeah and then we
ran into a guy right after that little
moments after you pulled your pants up
wait Griffith no no wait oh yeah well
we're at that River your hygiene levels
are going back to like colonial America
yeah say but you you are really I'm kind
of now I'm scared to mess with you at
all anymore can't believe you were
trying to hit water at me as I was
wiping my ass with my hands and
splashing that hand water at you and you
kept trying to get the last word in by
splashing I'm like we can keep doing it
myself no I would do it and then you
would stop and then you would like let
me get the last flash but it's like you
look okay Palestine Israel like what are
you doing when I definitely have the
upper hand here
quit being offensive give the upper Duty
AB listen you almost took a [__] in a
waterfall that were swimming like you've
gotten way too comfortable water falling
away though I feel like on your I didn't
have to [__] when you I heard you were
drinking out of the same water a man
with the same hand on my shoulder
here's though you hear what happened to
that the after-effects of that move Oh
God yone did some trouble and double
take when I got home I tell you this
that my girlfriend put her head on my
shoulder and I go by the way
ari took a [__] then wiped his ass with
his bare hand and then put his hand on
my shoulder and then she took a shower
and she freaked out she is pinkeye yeah
should ever I removed like handmaids
tonight yeah so I just think that you
went on this trip you got a little too
comfortable with the duty play I asked
if you were into it sexually though
because you see way too comfortable with
it you go I did [__] a lot on the trip
[__] a lot on the trip but I was no no
[__] play it was when I came back to
peak two American comedians who were
like oh you guys will get this yeah that
I you discovered [__] play overseas
there's some stuff you can't do with
those people that you don't really know
that what those people travelers like I
want they were eating food I want to
knock out of the hands but even
civilians like non comics probably
wouldn't enjoy that people who you know
wouldn't enjoy that non comics no right
but I mean I'm talking about yeah yeah
[__] Vietnam with them especially
yeah when you don't know it all but the
thing is when they bought those street
food over there it's like you just spent
40 cents on this so I find knock this
out of your hand it would be great it's
the perfect environment
I know monetarily and wouldn't someone
run out from the shadows and eat it off
the streets oh good I do your feeding
it's somebody somebody would probably
get it a cat
so you've like built all this up and
then you decided to unleash it because
you've gone you smeared the duty on your
face that got me thinking like it's for
fun you're going the other way with that
I've gone too far instead you know what
this is all right has there been any
anyone heard that and been like what are
you what's going on my brother female me
he was like about a punch our podcast
for the week after does he listen to the
ship no I think he saw something and he
goes did you really drink your own pee
and I was like yeah sorry that's
disgusting that's to which new laws oh
you don't want to watch to see the older
brother no younger younger okay I'm like
you know all actually before he said
well my do just I'm telling you don't
want to watch it and that the more is it
there do you if you would if you ever
visited my face but then I wiped it off
immediately
okay I'd say I'm gonna say it matters
but barely thank you and then why be
showing your under your eyes and then
walking about dude you're the GG Allin
of comedy is what you are except you
have the opposite because he had the
tiniest dick and balls and you have
giant [__] balls you be G Trump GG
Allin yeah I'm uh mm Allen do you ever
leave like for your family do you leave
what you left in the toilet for them
when you go home to visit I do not okay
Baba take a look at your upper Decker
your parents you reach a whole new level
of pranks do you ever like take a dump
on your dinner plate oh they put it
unstable you're like oh hey Bob fix it
your servants a real [__] lately that's
a wise it's a big Jay yeah big avenged
sevenfold fan yeah don't you just make
this up yeah I sort of I do yeah he
likes that kind of music but I see fans
have really taken to the Avenged
Sevenfold comments but he doesn't not
like Avenged Sevenfold but he doesn't
love them like you would love them but
he likes them he likes them but he likes
that caliber of music yeah garbage
people's music he toured with what
festival houses bluegrass and that's
like the Appalachians or whatever Jay
comes from garbage people and he
listened to the people of that garbage
people what did he tour without warrant
the corn tour yeah also uh Guare and who
was the high C Seoul ICP he says ICP
fits in Clown Posse fans are like the
worst humans in Juggalos Juggalos yeah
they probably they spray him with Faygo
maybe I don't know any band that has
like their own particular drink that
they like sprayed on their you gotta
watch out see those icy rock does ICP
gathering of the Juggalos they say uh
it's a it's like just like games all the
time
can be rough it's like white-trash
orgies like I'm gonna say there's like
zero Asian people who's ever been to
that probably like three black guys who
are on the wrong path definitely went
heavy white makeup in the clown so they
wouldn't be noticed yeah I think it's
also like just you know they do they
rent out like parks like campgrounds
yeah and then put a blockade on so if
cops like want to come in like in
private event do you have a warrant and
they go no we can look you can't look
because it's private event if you ever
want you to come in but otherwise no
sorry no one comes in and it's all
private security that's yeah then it's
like the be no violence there's no
reason for you to come you'll have no
calls and the guys can do drugs and
everything's fine yeah tells me ICP
hates their own fans they have to I
don't know I read an article and they're
like I mean they're making so much
[__] money I heard like they don't I
heard they'd [__] a lot of the chicks
and that's obvious but yeah this guy oh
it's a clown makeup though who's who he
sweated off that one guy looks like Guy
Fieri
yeah your life yeah the way the white
hair he looks like people do the
evolutionary chart it's a Smash Mouth
guy that guy in Fieri all look very
similar I fear he was actually in st.
cloud paws and be unbelievable it'd be
the Andy Kaufman of this generation the
greatest prank of all time what'd you do
to big J back on - oh so I wrapped a I
got him a Avenged Sevenfold
it's a new album ally no no odd but it's
a pre-release CD ooh very nice my notes
I know your favorite band is especially
unfold but other know in all seriousness
I know that you actually like Avenged
Sevenfold at very least so I got a
signed copy of the new album it's
spelled with the 7 in the front yeah
it's it's a avenged regular and then
seven with number 7 full with but no but
you don't put 7 full you put set as the
s7
evn yeah Wow seven Sevenfold 7 Evan fold
real stretch on that symbol music yeah
yeah it's real stretch how'd you get it
sign or do you use do so well so then I
wrap this this box it's like a
refrigerator box no it was like it was
sealed it was airtight
like
sealed box problems for tackle and stuff
okay you buy an air sealer yeah it was
clear so I wrapped on the outside and
then I wrapped it on the inside so we
couldn't see in kids wrapping off took
off the wrapping paper and then and then
could see it so I wrapped on the inside
as well with wrapping paper how long did
the packing take mmm
35 minutes but then maybe 30 minutes but
the pudding the present end was was the
more difficult part because what I did
was I put a sock a dirty sock on you
guys are like this because you had that
renan's ec thing yeah so I've been trash
pinata which is the evolutionary chart
of this videos about the trash manana I
loved it
we bought a pinata we're coming up on an
anniversary yeah it's birthday's coming
up birthday yeah with 32 we bought we
bought a sweet-ass pinata
because we wanted to do something
special for his birthday we actually
just had it no we searched it out I did
with yeah that we had a pinata later on
Oh
oh yeah we were gonna film something
yeah oh so that we said hey you know
what this would be perfect for zoos but
they're empty you know when you're lying
about obesity's birthday party yeah and
so they were like we can't fill it with
candy cause like people of it what's
with these two guys we're gonna reopen
yadda so it's too like it's too earnest
and also we just don't believe in sugar
everything it's bad for the system and
stuff so what we did was found some
rotten meat in his freezer I had a
roommate he had some tofu dogs that were
so slimy my vag six ears open leave
opened a can of tuna put the juice and
the tuna in raw and took some
tighty-whiteys and [__] streak them with
mustard and chocolate I believe was the
combo then a tampon then filled the
front of them with orange juice so I
think someone's edge [__] we have the
tampon with I think red wine and ketchup
yeah and then she has condoms yeah I
think there was a week on them with
stuff we don't like tapioca and
just so most other assorted meats then
on top like for unwrapped jellybeans
yeah just because like what if someone
reaches in at the bottom so that if it
broke the jellybeans would spill out
first
I'd be like what they don't tell you the
instruction manual for the pinata is
that when you put juicy Radek beated
there it starts to warp the cardboard it
starts to leak in the car the the
unicorn cow's belly started to really
sleep we're like we need to get there
quick this thing's gonna blow right more
tape though way outside of seal yeah to
like seal it in when we walked in the
first people we saw were like 48 year
old civilians and I turned on here I go
this is a bad idea this idea just got
way better now that there's civilians
here but when we brought it no one
suspected was like oh that was so nice
you guys ready thank you guys thanks
guys that's great let's make the party
hit a ping-pong table in the front yeah
we were shy was the last that was the
last party that Eliza was like actually
friendly with everybody oh is it me back
then or she was there that might have
been chubby Eliza still it's when he was
living next to Faye Dunaway Wow the
street from James Cromwell yeah was that
a king's road nose right off willoughby
member in Hollywood yeah he was renting
over there I think and that's when he
was living with Kim still and we're like
yeah live next sort of fade that way
then one day I'm driving and I see her
out there berating some guy cutting her
trees down really so at some point in
the party I was like let's get the
because we didn't want to push it too
heavy it was out there for like maybe
two hours and somebody let it sit in the
Sun let that meat baked a little bit
juice up a little more it's through the
pinata and they'd know we had no string
so they just like tied it up to the
garage handle that was like pulled up
yeah they like haphazardly blindfold
them spun them like once so that it was
beating it's surprising this thing I
liked it - well it was resilient he was
like really but then finally he busted
open and then the jelly beans fell he
busted it open like a cracks and it fell
off the garage and only one jelly bean
trickled out
Hertz grabs the jellybeans he's like Oh
jelly think we're gonna say don't eat it
look you should go see of war we looked
at each other but like [__] and we were
both like nope let it happen he put it
down though it was a bit we were like
ooh that was close it's not it's just
gonna be a casualty then Rena Z Z walked
over to it ripped it open cuz it it
wasn't that open on top
it was like what's it and then he
thought it well then he say it's dry
heaving its trash
and he started dry heaving into his
bushes they're digging out and they
pulls out the tighty whities and he goes
oh my god Brody yells out are those 34
great timing I'm Brody and that was he
goes off somebody the party was divided
we're like half for the people were like
that's brilliant half for like get these
two guys out of here people were like
not good work please were not pleased at
all it was clean up it was like trash
and meat on the floor
yeah good house that was a good house
that's great you can see the divide in
those things so what I did was I took
that sock I put it in up in the box and
then I took a dump on the side I was
waiting for the [__] when I heard the
packing any legal to mail [__] I think
the mail [__] unless I do mail it or
hand it to him no I know but I'm saying
if you can you send [__] I mean I think
you can send it if someone requests you
send the [__] but to just to surprise
them was [__] I think it might be
illegal yeah it's got to be like passing
I don't know what it so what if you're
mailing in like a stool sample that
illegal that's what the doctors probably
it's just a big loophole look at it
what's in the box so wheat so it was a
birthday present a party podcast on
legion of skanks and I sat there with it
in front of me did it smell an hour and
45 no airtight case ah this is where the
air did you spray it down with any like
Febreze just in case did you let the
[__] ferment for a while did you just
leave it out for a while is this a fresh
dump dude I [__] in it and closed it
immediately oh oh you just [__] on you
[__] right on the side of a sock in the
bottle know what you should've done like
why the sock I just thought it's better
just presentation yeah
left it out in the Sun and then cracked
it open you know like we step on some
dog [__] that's still soft in the middle
and then if I get what you're saying but
when he opened it the smell filled
instantly it was like you know when
scooby-doo screams into a bottle and the
seals it yeah and then when you open it
a full scream comes out like that
[__] it's like he was standing under
your [__] [__] smell came out it
cleared the room Ron bennington ran did
anyone get you call round did anyone get
nominated you know ran Michael che ran
everybody from the room next door start
clearing out of the bar today you're
nominated or throw some guy who was like
a crazy like Brian Cosme type start
yelling at me [__] man you're [__] up
it's [__] like a fan you so much
crazy person I'm gonna punch you did big
J stay yeah of course I know they closed
the box and I just kept kind of open
again citi piti at least shake the [__]
off and then look at the CD oh there was
no CD though there was no see I thought
you got it autographed he says he says
he gave Ari gave me a thing a [__] I'm
like I maintain that that was the CD
with listen to it man and it sounds the
same to me was that the worst part of
the prank for him is that there was no
CD so you [__] on a sock shouldn't sell
[__] in the sock then you could have
slapped options you could have slap
somebody with this well then you should
have made him try the sock on it's a
full load of [__] in there next time get
him some shoot new shoes but [__] and
then push it into the toes then he
slides in oh yeah cuz you could get sued
for that if he was really pissed not
dey's going to but I think that's like
bio hazard it's a biohazard say you have
the same lawyer how we can't work one of
you has to get whoever if he's decides
to sue you you have to get a new lawyer
away you can't kind of my lawyers
already my lawyer that's how it works
and said he's gonna have to get a
different look so you can't give an
entertainment lawyers to somebody for a
second is it the competition no it is
not the comment the guy who creeps one
[__] hookers all the time and then if
you bring somebody around a girl he's
like yeah how do you get down like hey
dude she's not a [__] hooker
and if she was she's with me so I should
lay the [__] off you [__] creep and
he's a lawyer
obey the law above the lines like Steven
Seagal do renegotiate so we left from
where did my comics or special we bought
a new carton still there thousand bucks
for that for that curtain one in the
back of the original room really yeah
that's a new [__] curtain that's
nuclear what was wrong with the old one
it was all torn and like I don't even
remember he looked at $1,000 long did
you sell it there's probably like Sam
Kinison ship taking it with you uh by
the way I'm taking this curtain with me
no so we said like hey by the way thank
you for letting us do this specially
we're gonna give you the curtain if you
want it we can put a bill curtain back
for this one is really nice and we'll
give it to you and he goes hey take that
out of the contract cuz I want to tell
Peter that I negotiated that smooth
exactly I made them get this curtain
smooth that's how you stay in business
the people who run the comments were
listening to that [__] sad I try not
to think about there are high ups have
him as their lawyer that's crazy
big entertainment figures I will not say
I will say after probably already gonna
get how about if I pretend to put a lot
pause then don't will you tell me
probably not I could mouth it but then I
would say Oh Ari's pausing it by hitting
the carpet yeah Ari are we is it Theory
pause please it's a Brad Pitt
whoa is it you lot oh you're supposed to
lock it off sometimes because it doesn't
the night waking up this house has no
insulation by the way we're at elevation
right now we are yelling it weird
Sherpas have to help us up dude you
don't even know this pretty good route
that we had to take to get here because
of the street cleaning I can't believe
you didn't just go left
I'm sorry I didn't think if they're
going right I almost went right cuz I
saw a spot there and now I know why what
are those two sticks you have a
beautiful on their horse
no how many ladies have you had in arias
more spikes but a few times
Aria is bedding out by the fire very
romantic yeah I literally thought you
were when I came in here the other day I
thought you were sleeping there I go you
do there's two bedrooms I thought like
you had default sleep there for a little
bit condition your body on these trips
in these third-world countries to sleep
on the floor
Ahri's love it for sure by the way sleep
on the floor with just a little bit of
cushion
unbelievable well I
agree really I love birthdays in a
monastery in [__] northern Thailand
on a yoga mat yeah good you didn't like
it no you can't there's no position
you're like ow ow you turn your side how
[__] the base ow
why are you hurt why were you in a
monastery Buddhist [__] retreat
trying to do a pasta no meditation for
[__] ten days how's that God it was
wait for 10 days you lasted 5 yeah no
it's up it's up to 10 days but you can
go as long as you want you get thrown
out for a [__] prank and they were only
there for three days did you feel like
did you really have like a rustling and
your soul of like for pranking that
these people wouldn't understand at the
meditation place or just traveling with
these people anyway like you're
traveling civilians you know when you
get civilian sight there's a common joke
I do they always gonna chill with girls
they'll be like texts I had a great time
last night
it's so much fun as always and then I'll
write like kill yourself yeah what the
[__] what's that supposed to mean I'm
like oh it's clearly at overboard
reaction that's why you were dick how
many of those did you send out before
you stop doing them six first day the
people out there the anon comments they
don't I just don't know that they'll get
stuff like that you know it's hard
because then also if they don't like the
[__] that you pull if they don't get it
you're pretty [__] for the rest of the
trip like they'll leave you that we're
not traveling with you anymore they
could kill you you don't know who you're
dealing with over there they could kill
you leave you in the bush there's
psychos out there
yeah don't travel with hot chicks that's
rule number one
that's it but I don't know if she did it
I don't yeah I know well I was that
proves that other [__] guy that ran
he's taking [__] in there I think dude
you would be the worst of UK I took a
huge [__] if you come out everybody's
dead yeah what would you do in that
situation while you were traveling I
mean I guess I'd call the cops were just
like I gotta go can you [__] out of
there oh I don't know cuz then it's like
you you don't really trust the police
there so now like you're like and you
have one witness that says oh I saw this
guy or you take it prank the guy
and he wants to get back at you and then
he turns you in yeah you just take a
match you burn the place down and you
plead you get your [__] you run for the
nearest border then you get an airplane
in another country to fly there's the
girl who got arrested the boogie board
scandal we go from Australia what with
all that weed she got arrested with weed
and her boogie board case she claims
it's not hers they claim it was where
was Indonesia Bali Bali life in prison
oh no dude they they arrest these these
five Australians a black male to bring
black male by the [__] mafia oh by
the drug cartel they said well Ike will
kill your family we have this whatever
it was and today I said you have to go
there and like it's it's it's a death
sentence if I get caught they're like
well it's out of that or this I'm
guaranteed death or maybe death I think
they're putting him into death they
might have commuted it to life sentences
and they said they should prove to him
like we're bring blackmail they go yeah
we don't care rules the rule [__]
crate were you scared
did you smoke weed over there yeah sure
and were you worried at all no not at
all I smoked weed in Lombok there's an
island Indonesia not Bali I'm to die on
some Bali to unlock the street people
this guy you weren't worried there's
like undercover cop who had like a a tin
can in his shirt with a string that went
to another guy with it did yeah there
was a surf instructors brother might
have been huck from the comedy store x.x
secret police we're friends [__] you hey
what the [__] go [__] die you're
going to die girls you going to [__]
die I'll die st. for [__] born a
little tip accept Christmas you die now
he hates dies because he gave him a
carcass of a turkey what do you mean Oh
dice brought in what's left of it
he had my Dan Madone eeeh who was at his
Thanksgiving dinner bring in a turkey
and I was there in the kitchen you know
it's like Thanksgiving night no one's
there yeah and it's covered in tin foil
and Hawk goes to inspect it he was
probably hungry yeah and he was not
impressed the amount of meat left on
those bones tell dice thankful [__]
bone thanks for [__] born
did you at all think of looking him up
while you were there dice no hawk yeah I
think he's a kid I was in northern
Thailand and only I was only supposed to
be there for a stopover and then I got
distracted with all that [__] so I
stayed like 15 days but I didn't
expected hell of a distraction I know
what would you do if you saw him in the
monastery but then he just gave you the
hand over the mouth as Shh like he was
on the road look hey he's the kind of
guy that I could see if you just ran
into him in Thailand he'd be like yeah
hey and then he would just walk away
could be he just doesn't give up or not
even the yeah hey just nod and then keep
moving or he's with his Thai friends and
just acknowledge that yes you know we
know each other that's it did you talk
to heart at all before you went to
Thailand hook up with some of his family
to sleep on their floor or something the
last time we did PDC went yeah oh you
did you saw Hart's family no I told him
I was going what should I do
oh yes yeah I think we were gonna see
Huck and then I had to shoot some
[__] awful movie great while you're
in Thailand the tide action star ja
his name Tony Jaa yeah yeah oh yeah
Pitts still sweaty are they Jude is it
dude that hike was unbeli telling you it
was no it's cool in here now right it's
hot it's hot which we open that window
maybe get some cross ventilation
why you go on hikes just walk those
stairs man do the stairs stairs that go
up like eight hundred blocks yeah
they're everywhere in this neighborhood
there looks nice that's the stats real
nice look at that we live in the lap of
luxury over we've got some more Spears I
know cuz I made smores in there in the
fight with no girl this is great was she
impressed yet so while we oh it's too
late now you want to do a fire right now
yeah let's do s'mores right now dude
it's hot as hell no no but it's in the
shape I'll do this breeze coming in his
gourd let's let's bring the fire pit in
here at the rental dude who cares you
want to go make us do you want us pause
this go get a fire and do this with
s'mores over a fire pit we could totally
do that
do it what time you got to leave five
4:30 4:30 yeah let's do it
that sounds fun all right we're eating
[__] s'mores yeah okay I have all the
things for actually I have all the
research they would okay so they have
the the marshmallows chocolate graham
crackers it's more cast do we have to
strip some wood off this place
we might happen I have one log that's
all I have for wood he had a few logs in
the toilet and you flush them who logs
is all you need ones - yeah perfect
all right so we don't do this pause this
set that fire up we'll get those s'mores
going yeah do it dude I'm get out you
don't I swear to god I'll [__] punch
you dude get away [__] don't drop it on
me right swear to God I will take a [__]
I gotta rub in your mouth I swear to god
dude I'm gonna TP you get away [__]
[Laughter]
don't kick his head too hard dude I'm
gonna no I swear to god I'll kick you so
hard in the stomach right now do you
look at my leg look where it is it's
ready to team it's coiled to not throw
we're being threatened by an [__]
bloody ass napkin root hey wait what
late dude if you sort it one of us both
of us will hold you down and we'll label
this oh we get this spear you with it we
get a boner
dude we will hold you down to find a
high heel and I will stomp your nutsack
with it like a hammer no dude I swear to
god it's gonna be serious retaliation
from window care I see the bees at the
duty play no I can't I swear to God
don't wave don't don't I'll throw a
chair through that front window the wind
could take it carry it over in my
direction you gotta stop
alright alright I wash your head she's a
take a shower you're a terror like God
smell it oh look it look it dude do it
dude I will I will jump out this window
I'll probably go through the floor will
dump it I'll dump it on zip it let's put
a lot pause no you wait here I'll dump
it
oh my god I got a piece I need a weapon
too I got a load that is one thing that
uh nodded to put it out there bloody ass
your hand you gotta wash your hand you
want s'mores from this man I'm making my
own about having it put his equipment
yeah but the fire will kill it all what
do you think he does [__] long sticks
I've got I bet you he doesn't wash him
for one we should I would chop his
[__] fingers off those things are so
riddled with duty it's unbelievable his
fingernails must have do this is the
problem when you go it is his turf don't
know I think there are cameras in here
by the way oh well I guarantee you
they'll never rent Tahari again you
might get banned from air B&B they're
like we've there's so much fecal matter
that you leave behind by the way your
neighbours right now are probably like
it's so what being raped with that
bloody toilet paper Christ okay okay
yeah good we're on alright back by the
fire the fire
welcome to fireside chats with Ari
Shaffir it's a new podcasting thing he's
doing and he does it
it starts at noon on a Friday
oh no fire is a good idea for June in LA
it's surprisingly comfortable back here
though it's better than the courtyard
will courtyard behind the house I feel
that Ari's gross this somehow gets
diffused when you go outside the only
thing that's gonna limit what I say is
that there is a camera that the
homeowners have placed attached to the
back of the home you'll forget what that
in three minutes
I stayed that Rena skis ease house and
hammers yes doorbell he would talk to me
through the doorbell
look where else does this guy I've came
when he was turned up in a few gonzo
porn just this face though you think
what are you doing O'Neil
alright let's wait wait you don't have
aren't you can use an official fix ya a
official sport what do they call him no
but I mean I have like more Spears have
I have fireplace ticks well these it's
called the poet it's fine dude do we got
enough fire to make s'mores I'm saying
what this going and I'm not sure it's
really going you're a big he's really
big into getting the fire raging but
it's this is a small little pit I'm
gonna start cooking my s'mores
yeah the roof the roof is on fire exists
oh no oh no there it goes its back
alright we're back alright Jeff we don't
touch those don't touch those
marshmallows we encourage you at home to
get your own fire going and light some
s'mores up while you listen O'Neill is
getting his first so here's your's go
camping oh I got this you can use that
one I'm not gonna do it so you wanna
just I'm cool yeah I'm not a s'mores man
O'Neill spill the marshmallow I mean
keep in mind we're only barely anything
but it only has to be enough soft
marshmallow but my sides [__] raging
it's not it's raging dude I know what a
rage is and this is not that this is a
rager should I wait okay you know you
know what it needs is a juicing sure can
i juice it
yeah where's the juicer yeah give me
that juice Jack LaLanne yeah give me
that juicer be careful with the juice
look Ari don't weave the juice dude
don't with the juice you want a good
juicing sometimes you gotta play with
fire so here we go
I might juice my marshmallows to get a
good toast on them so you're not gonna
Jesus no no no no do not put [__]
kerosene on your Marshall no I think
that was a jail but we don't know we'll
find out I should be I should be in a
standing position for this dude it's
barely going right now oh yeah geez stop
something just needed a good juicing man
who's saying [__] nothing like the smell
of lighter fluid and fire but then it
goes though now no no my sides good are
your real stickler for fire got the
juicer please pass the juicer passengers
please this is our if you want to know
what we're using it's Ronson all lighter
fluid just your traditional it's an old
the favourite for sponsorship no dude
it's gonna follow up the flavor wait
yeah that's got a good juice on it
there's a real Charbroil the logs dude
way if you really want the fire to get
going put that fresh log right in there
and it's gonna go big fresh longer we
can really cook s'mores we're talking
wood yeah it might melt this contraption
but it'll get it going real good put all
the fixings on there whoa don't burn
that cord yeah yeah here we go
this shit's about to get fresh pro-level
fire right here now keep in mind that
you have way too many logs in this small
contraption this is like the microwave
of fire pits very soon it's about to get
going right now yeah it's about to get
real shit's about to go down I was gonna
I was on a on Lombok in that place where
I did the weed did the weed
please called like Lombok California
Rock Lompoc yeah we just looked at yeah
that's why it's a man way to a wedding
there Lompoc I went to the wedding there
and in January maybe the city of Lombok
it's possible this your sister this tiny
little wine town how do they decide
sister cities they're so random it
really is like I guess we're linked now
wait who's I LA as a sister city who it
is it uh it's Bakersfield Dublin I don't
know there's like signs downtown that
says its sister city somewhere I was
like I don't really oh my see yeah
not my sister so you can't [__] women
from that part of the world we're all
related yeah all right so you were
smoking the weed weed I see we had a
fire we got a fire going on this hill
overlooking the ocean and the wind would
rip through it so fast every time you
put a logger in there just be up and
like no nothing cuz of the [__] rocks
everything was better over there in high
school I went to a party and there had a
fire but that was poison ivy
I think that someone put on it or hell
yes you hear that there here it is dude
that's crackling oh there it is it
should just got real [__] just got real
yep we're on oh [__] sorry for throwing
that on there from the beginning yeah
Ahri's balls roasting on an open fire
that's the snap crackle pop of your nuts
if you put that duty on us we'd [__]
butcher them like that I mean it might
back and forth my head it was like just
throw it just throw it up just throw it
on them if this were like three if you
were three years younger you would have
thrown it but I think you've matured
over the years I would have sounded you
with that s'more spear oh yeah I would
have gone through your butt hole and
then made it come out your dick hole
kabaah who shoved it yeah more spear
dick kabob and then put re over the fire
yeah this more do kabob all right why
didn't you ever tell Rogen my term for
one guys are when a guy has a guy's back
and then he turns while he's in that
position I called it the rotisserie why
didn't I ever tell him that yeah I
didn't remember partially also I have no
interest in talking to him about that
the rotisserie what a guy's like what a
guys on top and the guy underneath is
like goes from his back to his stomach
back to his back I think you need to
tell the rotisserie to talk to Eddie
Bravo about that he's really okay well
then I'll bring it up to any problems
I'm [__] ready with those I know I
got them right here I got to I got my
primary crackling crackling but I feel
like it caught on the it has caught on
that right it's raging dude it's on my
side yeah it's your side it's a rager I
don't even know how I'm gonna get my
s'mores in there to take your top off
just for my
take your top off Fridays can you get
this off he's gonna burn your hand take
this off that's gonna bring oh [__] take
that off
just put a stick under it and fling it
you're gonna bend it oh let me see if it
works I'll do that like that you may
have just [__] over the top I already
see it no I don't let's just shove it
you may have just it's gonna run right
up there so we don't have to like open
it up yeah the heats rising this is like
mr. whizzy oh this is like backdraft but
the backyard version of the movie so
let's see okay so we had this problem in
Joshua Tree with his marshmallows
roasted real [__] weird went through
them but he's the same ones no different
one okay these are the good ones
these are craft now the other were
Walmart Walmart Brent and they [__]
burnt by the way I don't know if I
believe that ice people were talking
about the ice burning differently no
that's just how ice burns when an
extreme heat yeah it rides on a layer of
its own water yeah I gotta go in there
was that hot as [__] was this hot I'm
gonna use this oh yeah here we go this
guy's taking selfies I've got his dude
first of all jump rope fell so I'm
trying re spent maybe four hours burning
marshmallows in the fire Joshua Torres
straight marshmallows
he was obsessed with how they they did
burn we're throwing in the fire they
like grew they would burn and then they
would grow why are you putting it on the
log just cuz I'm trying to like get it
off my thing I'm done with it fell on
the floor I welcome here oh hi Scott's a
Big Smoke me oh look at oh she's gone to
burnish it bad no to get like you know
if you burnt bread they say it's a
carcinogen really yeah do you know what
I don't know Matt I don't know the
science behind that's a good question
maybe they do i but do you know what
they say what they say is you shouldn't
eat they say burnt steak is but then
they also say people that grill out a
lot also smoke and drink a lot and maybe
that's the culprit not the birth and
they're also 486 pounds hold on only
so yeah Jeff you know whatever what you
know what drugs do you do Jeff I don't
do a lot of drugs would you ever do
mushrooms I did them in high school yeah
really in high school yeah wait before
me fortunately they were weak cuz I
don't know if I could handle it I feel
like you could though but maybe not I
mean maybe not you gotta go over the
first one Ryan did eventually yeah I
feel like we didn't set this up right at
all we started going and then now we're
doing stuff with our hands and it's way
harder this is a huge mistake doing a
podcast like this so you have them you
have no [__] chocolate though no it's
horrible
well it's the order what's the Ari
Shaffir order of s'mores you can't hear
it all cuz you're not [__] putting
your mic by your face put it on your
face pick it up O'Neill's got this smell
oh there's the chocolate
he's got marshmallow on his thumb yeah
horrible narration okay here we go
that was world-class alright yeah maybe
I don't know if this was the best let's
focus here all right new podcast yeah
and a new show we're trying to get going
called knockers yeah check out the
Facebook page is it about boobs you saw
the thing it has a Stephen ask easy in
it oh really yeah
it's about we're not allowed to say no
we can I mean you go to the podcast and
I was talking about names for fat Steve
and people on Twitter been like giving
me like a thousand of them laughter the
last two days about Steve on obesity
she's running a Pete see diabetes
diabetes diabetes yeah I like these if
he overweight right now he likes his
chicken parms man he goes to New York
everything in a while it is funny that
when you look back at those
early years you forget like he was a
bigger boy he was a bigger boy didn't I
think he started out like I think it's
ordered bigger they make weight when he
came to LA I think as a child he was a
bigger guy yeah cuz his dad's [__]
massive and his dad listens to the show
by the way huge fan is that he was oh he
will only eat out if it's
all-you-can-eat buffet man like it's a
pile disappear I like that you gotta
respect that you gotta respect that
you can't knock his hustle of wanting to
just put on the pond and I'm keeping
them on Hometown Buffet men no we went
to the Paris Buffet and uh Negus Negus
Vegas yeah oh you must love hate is like
not opera for him yeah yeah what's his
dream he was living in the high life
there every every meal in Vegas is
buffet style he was like I'm gonna go
back for seconds and there's one more
seconds you're right technically that's
thirds yeah and then two more seconds
and then he is like now dessert buffet
the buffets I don't like the mixing of
foods a lot of times also can't nail all
of these foods is great items you know
there's too much to me that's why I hate
restaurants that have a big menu cuz
you're not doing all of these good right
exactly
I agree with that I agree with that
you're you're giving up what in and out
that's it yeah you want a special you
don't go to a doctor who knows a little
bit of everything you go to a specialist
well you can afford that yeah none of us
can Oh helicopter see this more is
coming in I really think these wind
chimes are gonna add to the bus
spiritual element because it sounds like
we're in a church yeah so how are things
going for you guys now for Danish you
know me um um I tried to enlist in the
military but they wouldn't take because
I'm too old really - really I thought I
could see that totally talks about it
every now and then so that I could see
that being true inquiring the Google
research and then like now I'm not
really into it but I just wanted all the
I do want to know all the facts I'm
definitely too old to go Air Force and
like learn how to fly a helicopter that
should be my backup plan he talks about
that a lot and he wants flying a
helicopter yeah he doesn't like that his
vision would hold you back not in the
helicopters and also I think they fixed
it with the Jets like you can have
corrective surgery now and I would never
train me for jets they have corrective
windshields no way you're 38 39 no but
they will not take you know do they want
like a 20 year old yeah they don't want
me like well how many years am I gonna
give these guys haven't you ever seen
Necessary Roughness Scott Bakula was a
hell of a quarterback it's never too
late to be a quarterback
yeah that's career in Kathy Ireland was
a great kitchen
he was just him behind the candelabra
the best movie of the past decade just I
was like was it 2 3 years ago it was
Michael Douglas and I talk about this
all the time because I can't promote
this movie enough Matt Damon and yeah
and it's Liberace and these guys are
having a great time playing LeBron yeah
Liberace goes to a claw he loves glory
hole exactly how stupid can be that was
he was like yeah we're joining that
where you could tell that they were bolt
totally in on it just loving the joke of
it it's a great film yeah was it really
dude one of the most entertaining films
of the decade no joke I'd likely made
that guy have surgery to look more like
Liberace it's great
his boyfriend his boy toy Matt Dame
Scott I just remember hearing about
Liberace all the time when I was a kid
in the 80s yeah like he was a big deal
like now you're like whatever Liberace
but you never hearing about him when it
was like he got AIDS
I remember tackling he got AIDS how he
was so manly you look at pictures lady
like oh yeah what do you mean how
but back then no one thought of anyone
as gay really yeah you're just like I
don't like gays like what are they what
makes a game I don't know I just don't
like them yeah but also yeah well now
you look at you go nobody knew this guy
was gay are you out of your he was see
mine your sequins head to toe I remember
him I met I think WrestleMania one or
two
maybe not up yeah he was dude you got to
give it to the McMahon family they
really do how to cross-promote [__] oh
they had Cindy lop yeah they really
brought in pop culture instead of the
wrestling world videos no the captain
Lou albano up in the wall bottom he
became like an actor remember he was in
wiseguys with Joe Piscopo really dude
the rubber bands man they really and he
was in some was that other shitty 80s
comedy that he was in one with Hulk oh
goes that no-holds-barred or was it
something or so what those two idiot
twin bodybuilders remember those I think
he was in that I think so
remember those two idiot twin
bodybuilders that had like a brief run
in movies though they played like just
blew up in there we're all gonna smell
like smoke so that's my god dammit
O'Neill O'Neill G is the marshmallow to
the closest Hershey's wrapper rookie
mistake people to eat on podcast you
listen to our podcast you guys don't
listen to podcast to you
I used to out my man audiobooks now and
I'm still trying to get through it it's
45 hours and 27 minutes yeah it's two
days of reading it's just do it straight
you should just do it straight dude I'm
only like 19 hours three only 19 we
should do a contest do you do it
straight I read next to you straight and
we see all you'll beat it you'll beat
him I mean like because when you read
this guy's acting it out and you know
he's taking the dramatic pause like hold
on I'm gonna go grab something to drink
and then nobody can tell that he like at
one point had to take a [__] because in
it just like abrupt cut farted and they
caught it good gig to get we should get
that audio book reading yeah I can read
read what book was you read do you have
to read it's [__] you got to read it
perfect you got to read it
right through like but that's like edit
so it's like they can't know this guy's
the Denzel washes your house are
frustrating that we'll read it in one
take what take you match that I only
want audiobooks they were done at one
take you know what guys that are
stopping and restarting again mistake it
had two people whole mistakes or the
best guy ever
I want guy that's your ought like
realistic audiobook readings where a guy
goes to the bathroom you just it's just
dead air comes back yeah you're [__]
it up for me okay nobody's here this guy
has like tinfoil on his windows and some
weird [__] I don't even know like you
know some of these houses up here in
these hills that are really nice then
you look and you're like this is like a
hoarders paradise it's like old people
bought this in like the 60s dude there
was this woman that rented the 50-foot
woman movie yeah yeah so they just found
her dead and decomposed in her house
hurt like her deck had like falling in
we her deck with fallen in with the
movie she was in it no she was the woman
from it actually bought this house when
she had money and then just stop doing
any repairs to it and then she'd and
then all that attack of the 50-foot
woman money right by the the radiator
who doesn't want to be mummified in
their own trash dude all those residuals
stop coming in and she couldn't pay for
the house anymore
and spend most is the tough thing about
this town man is like you never know
when it's over
you know you're still like I can get
back I can get an audition piece
somebody else today some director City
he mentioned yeah I guess they love
50-foot woman helping me in something oh
really he wants a 50 think of the guys
that even when we came out here some
guys were huge and now they're they've
disappeared
but like how can it work with like
somebody from Greece who was it I was
before you guys got there a guy with the
Hunchback Greece the addict oh yeah
Jeff Conway he died right he did he did
the dingdong show a few times it was
like riding with him for a while early
on
on Celebrity Rehab yeah he was that guy
had he was addicted to painkillers from
all that back surgery and Mickey was
done smoked right to me but who would
have thought that that guy I loved it
bugs won't bother you I love coming in
and just smelling like smoke fire
especially your hair dude that hair I'm
gonna have to cut it off about to shave
it but that's that is the scary thing of
it all like it could be over yeah well
then they gotta save that's the thing
you gotta save that's why I hate the
property taxes the idea of it where it's
like much of money buy a house good
enough we're in Florida it's like no
you're not you still at 1.5% your house
is worth what let's say $100,000 that
means you owe $1,500 every every what if
your house is worth 1.5 million you got
to pay 15 [__] grand wait how often
it's property is everyone here 1.5%
every year every year yeah yeah and
fifteen hundred you can okay but if you
have a house is $500,000 $300,000 so
it's forty five hundred bucks but if you
have no income like no I just wanna live
off the grid you can't you have to come
up with 4500 bucks every year and earn
that money with taxes that means you're
gonna make $7,000 that's why these guys
these big stars when they do when they
buy a fifteen million dollar house
you owe a hundred and twenty grand a
year just in property tax when [__] goes
bad it's you had you you have to pay a
good salary
Tristan property tax they've got a guy
on that shitty reality show mountain men
on that what Huestis he was off the grid
they got him for taxes taxes would be
honest how his property they just never
paid it yeah and then he had to like
probably do some Kickstarter he's on a
reality shows he's getting money right
he also has probably selling that
beargrease yeah killed a squirrel he
says some neighbor guy who like does all
his work it's like he lives off the grid
it was like Carolina yeah it's like two
autistic people just barter and burgers
I forget his friend and he likes this
haha we had a guy who listened to our
podcast who knew Eustace yeah
the Danish milk podcast yeah you know
and boner City our old podcast but uh so
use this and this guy always do things
together and he's like one time they
shot a squirrel and he's like used to
I brought along this bear grease which
is his fat in a jar and I recognize
light on the squirrel Oh ma'am that
really made the squirrel so much better
that part is I would love to I would I
would love to just live like that just
shooting squirrels carrying a jar of
bear grease around with me and if you
make it
I mean squirrel meat must taste good
after it's all right you got to really
get that hair off you got a skin it good
I've had someone just burn hair world
yeah we seed square all the time
[Laughter]
conversation that he thinks other people
like of course for Thanksgiving we would
always go yeah every morning for
Thanksgiving or Christmas we would go
out and shoot ducks
so we'd have fresh duck to eat really
yeah let's go out there what if there
were no ducks out there well
occasionally that would happen but you
bring that quacker what do you call it
yeah I also just do it with my hand
they come with their boaters ready to
[__] I'm here for the gangbang if you
miss the first shot do they all fly away
or just well usually you scare them out
of like oh we had a creek that ran
through our farm see the dog going
through well no a lot of times you would
come up on him you'd see him go and then
you shoot you know you want to shoot him
when they're in the air you don't want
to blast them out of the water at anyone
ever bring the Nintendo duck gun yeah
one time yeah one time my brother did he
accidentally brought it dropping so he
kept lowering the gun and then putting
it back up yeah we once saw some
firearms I won't say we're with Steven J
Ren is easy firearms and he was dry
firing the gun which Emile did not
appreciate hey let's just stop pull the
trigger like 50 times it's bad for the
gun Oh Annie Get Your Gun
lard-ass is easy
our NASA ever stand by me the old
lard-ass yeah
was it great you remember lard ass like
lard ass life every season he drank the
castor oil member they're like Gordy or
the best storyteller of all time he
could have been on your that show you
did like tell a story in Gordy tells a
story about lard ass and he's at a PI
competition and he hates it they come
they go boom Bob when he walks up and so
he drinks the castor oil show them to
teach him a lesson
and he pukes in everywhere yeah by the
way that worked out for him and Sam I'm
a butt like a fat guy puking because he
ate too much would not make you have
less taunts no more would increase
muscle on you would get the [__] beat
out of you think you just puked on me
fat [__] you [__] out of you they
already hating lard ass the whole crowd
was chanting hard it really turned on
lard ass though he was one of their own
wouldn't they root for him because he
was like representing the town I think
you know what here's what we don't know
about him what was his like what was he
like jerk so I can't get behind the guy
cuz I don't know what he was like the
human outside of the pie-eating contest
right that's all they showed yeah this
is the glimpse into his life that you're
gonna give me just everyone's chanting
lard ass for a reason I mean you know
what I mean I thought it was a sign if
you were there let's say you knew nobody
you were there I would be the guy
starting it he was like how old do you
think lard ass wasn't years old 13 I
think by the way I think he's wearing a
fat suit I don't know Florida s was that
big also how about the casting for that
so or now you're gonna be playing lard
ass so in this seed we're gonna chant
lard ass and then you have no word you
know why I want you to feel it though
like really feel it really feel that
throw-up
you're really puke at home yeah and
again no lines in this this is just we
just need your fat body such a method
actor that he was really puking and did
severe damage to his to his esophagus if
they did 10 takes of it ate a hole in
his teeth
oh look at that dude you got a good
twist going dude are you the swisco then
we got fire are is the candy master dude
you never participate in the s'mores
there anything like this or if you go to
coffee with this guy
yeah no coffee no no drink it all good
I'll get the caffeinated tea oh you do
now or water oh yeah I drink herbal tea
- not too caffeinated decaffeinated
I don't like caffeine just a regular
green tea you don't get like a small
amount of caffeine in it what green tea
is a small amount of caffeine but it's
not gonna hurt ya well I'm with you I
don't drink caffeine so once in a while
drink green tea or English breakfast tea
but generally like Kim why don't you
like caffeine just hit me weird it's
like why bother I didn't I never drink
Coca Cola then it's like have you ever
performed though with on caffeine yeah
that's [__] great I did have it in in
East Timor a lot cuz they are the last
organic coffee in the world that ever
was like you're not drinking see more
coffee and I was like no no no more
coffee
I'm like alright sure so they basically
bullied you into drinking it I was a
little out my life why you turned it
into a bully yeah yeah it's like a child
molester so this is way better than I
would be okay Jesus you were molesting a
lot and bullied yeah and so I only went
and the book the Melissa wasn't bullying
they were like hey there's a cool room
unless you're like yeah okay so they got
your consent so it wasn't actually a
molestation
it was molestation because I couldn't
really give consent if you're underage
did feel pushed around
was it other children that were less
than you or is it like adults both yes
both was pretty much I was the molesty
boy you were the go-to guy in the
neighborhood they called me [__] boy yo
you're the originator of your time [__]
away spelled with it is it Bo I yeah I
think it is oh [__] see dude you went
chocolate on a bad move bad move dude
already dropped John do is say hi how
you gonna slide that thing off where'd
you get those salmon Reds
oh oh now you got to lick the tip
[Laughter]
dude what the [__] that was a real pro
level design right there yeah oh I see
you posted a picture with you in a
[__] and you said that you lost your
virginity did you have sex with a
[__] opportunity to her well your
[__] virgin but she could have [__]
your ass I could have been virgin that
is a type of virginity that I still have
yeah so could you tell us um you wanted
to but what happened she wasn't into you
or you about one but a different one
what was her name
if you want this now you talking about
the the last time you want any was
traveling in Thailand give a shout-out
for your favorite [__] drop the name
there's one look like Rihanna Rhiannon
she was great Rihanna
Rihanna's brother how about Rihanna I do
one of those reviews just to two of them
that like I can't tell Cher
I can't tell is there a cher there was
usually a share it was like the biggest
woman Britney Spears I could see
probably a lot of no Christina Aguilera
no Kelly Clark Ellie Clarkson oh well
yeah but so they they Asian Beyonce's
yeah but what if they could be Asian
Kelly Clarkson yeah do they get fighters
though like say there's another Beyonce
are they like this [__] prostitute
Ali is only big enough for one Beyonce
and one of them becomes Kelly Rowland
nobody wants to [__] Kelly oh the one in
Destiny's Child and then the other one
no one even knows her name
nobody want something that just be like
how pissed are you someone should be
like Janis Joplin just like we're like
rags is Bo and like a drunk her muff
must have been so horrible the pits were
probably hair I mean she was hairy right
uh-huh she probably had hair put on
vegetables when it was like 85 degrees
of hot or outside the butthole hair must
have been dude she probably washed her
[__] hair with the [__] that makes it
thicker like a thickening agent okay you
know just like you know like hey you
want thicker hair just [__] giant
clump and she never showered oh you
would her would have had some good duty
sure I guarantee you she was into duty
play is there a Mama Cass [__] yeah
run is easy well I thought were that's
what we're doing four years ago now he's
the trim man no he's kidding him it's so
much more fun to make fun of my friends
when they get fatter it's so you know it
hurts everybody so much to like deep
down well yeah I mean in front of these
you heard this he would really would
really hurt him just like a lot of
things that you say to people just
really hurt their feelings
you like to cut deep but comics were
like well I'll never show the pain we
can I'll never share that we drown my
sorrows and chicken parms we should do a
remake of stand by me but it is easy you
think guys
I'm not that big I don't even know if
they would allow it like people would go
crazy if you chained in lard or somebody
today camp you can't remake it you
couldn't even say like fat spot talk
about all in the family like you can't
say [__] like that anymore it's like TVs
going backwards like it was just
straight racist a lot though yeah it
just righted itself yeah accuses
dropping n bombs for problematic another
episode they were saying like [__] for a
for a laugh like you that's that's it
didn't sell you can't say that it's just
like it wasn't right probably use that
as it would like to get a higher purpose
I'll summon the family it was still some
other people in the family
Oh Sanford and Son oh is he like the
differences Jeff something was a spinoff
a lot they did they wouldn't spin off
the Jeffersons was a spinoff of the the
the one with the JJ wasn't it with that
I know my what's happening with that no
what's that show wasn't it good times
good times was it Jeffersons needs a
spinoff of the good times JJ Walker Oh
was it I think I don't know well I'm
sure we'll find out weaponize airs
comedy when I start comedy jaywalk we're
still coming around sometimes and never
so he was like maybe right before yeah
way I'd like two years before you guys
got there about that
two or three years okay know my music I
don't do the dynamite anymore and it's
like well write a graph the bad he would
announce it please never do it I mean it
was like a dynomite
oh dude no all right but nobody cares
about anything else from you like yeah
you had one thing man it's not like
people are like I'll do it or just don't
do it you don't to mention it yeah
people are like hey we'll just do
whatever's left in your repertoire of
the night where the actor John Amos
really took offense to Pete Carboni why
he was heckling Carboni why I don't know
if he thought he was like David oh no
Taylor went out first and then [__] on
him and then carbone's like you're
heckling me now he kinda I think felt
like he had been gotten the best of my
David Taylor plus I'm sure he did so
rather than take it out on him he took
it out on Pete Carboni and Pete Carboni
came offstage and he's like I thought it
was Joe Frazier mr. McDowell from coming
to America yeah McDowell's what'd you
just Chuck and [__] in the fire why so
back to why hey let me ask you this at
what point were you ready to quit and
give up or were you ever yeah I was a
lot man I mean up until what white-label
years ago some days you are and some
days some days some months I'll tell you
my comparison later so uh - what is the
quitting but like I mean not getting
passed for a long time to me that that
bother you that bother me for sure
because we were that we were pissed and
we got passed at The Comedy Store but
then it was like stupid mister who's
gone yeah and we lost our good spots at
employees spot we got two a week and
they were primetime and there's an
audience for bad spots no I was happy to
finally so we're like can we not be can
you just not pass as we don't wanna be
passed I've been looking into getting
unpassed I want to become an employee
again that's good idea yes dude this
[__] Monday night I hosted this week
potluck oh yeah how was this great long
she I was pissed that they moved it to
Monday I was like that's not fair one
good night scared you moving into
[__] the worst night of the week
the long [__] but if you act in there
but then is packed I'm like oh of course
I should move with them also where were
you
kids like like open my curls like I
start over you did and you could be just
like me if you work hard and stay in
school right say it like that but I did
say like this is the show I started in
school than yeah host it we're people in
a while we're some open mic errs like
starstruck no but I was passing people
so somebody would get off and be good
I'm like hey John Smith that was great
man
how's it go thanks with your past doers
paid regular right there he's passed
everybody I wonder if one of them did
college sometimes like really like yeah
really sure yeah yeah sorry passed me
here for call it spot I remember how to
do it but then I'm like oh yeah it
[__] [__] on people just comes
naturally they make it easy did you put
it I didn't want to go up cuz like
you're gonna make fun of me I'm like oh
yeah even if you do well I'm gonna make
fun of you he was a reluctant
Impressionists that was like his thing I
would you did you have a toilet paper
stuck in your [__] that as a joke
okay the audience is so gassed by the
end of that show they really are okay
when the paid regulars 9:30 I was like
what happened you guys we're almost done
like you stick with me you almost got
done at 9:00 like 10 o'clock
dude I was finished with the last
potluck or I've been the last with less
employee at 10:12 and then I did my time
Wow I've been done by 10 but it depends
if like some no-shows on employees help
there were so few no-shows the list is
so long so long it's crazy long I still
did a little bit between but I couldn't
really go nuts sometimes yet they really
go fast you're like when I had a court
cases about like who blew who like a big
dog upload my food yeah it's like this
took like 30 minutes and I can still
finish on time because we had so you
always were on time dude now it's like
they're guys who've been fired there for
like 10 years doing spots
what do you mean like there are guys who
don't work yeah yeah some people came by
as that can I go up no they're on the
list of them on the list
I just haven't taken off yet know that
yet I've been fired the hard part is is
going up in the paid regular portion
after that because they've literally
seen probably 45 comics get tired from
not just saying the amount of time you
watched but the amount of comedians you
watch it to read your mind has to
readjust to each comic so it's like take
some mental like it's hard I'd studied a
lot of work yeah they're done by that
unless they come in new but they're done
like a lot of them leave - they like
I've seen way too much yeah no I've see
too much just like if you weren't to a
movie and they just kept replaying
movies eventually you'd get up and be
like I can't take this okay
but the freakshow elements gone and that
breaks breaks my heart
which is sad that was that was our
potluck which is like yeah there's no
free as a host that was like the thing
you had to look forward to he's like at
least I'll have a couple freaks on here
there's nothing really that funny about
someone genuinely trying and failing
right there's something funny about a
freak who thinks they're great yeah it
talks trash it's spelling it hard yeah
and you're like that's so terrible it
was like yeah they have their sayings
going in like I'm number one tip top I
go it's like overconfidence is hilarious
like jail if Jesse just bobbing and
really wanting to do praise a minute
musical intro to a three minute set Wow
yeah it's great yeah always go chop down
the dancing o'clock stars but the dance
is great I know but you only have three
minutes so maybe in an hour so you'd
have to go up to somebody because it was
no sound guy on Monday and be like hey I
need this whatever he had a CD I'm
assuming way let's see all right in that
you know find someone to do it and it
did nothing ridiculous like the song at
the beginning so weird those freaks
Boone would do music interlude for Boone
would it was a reason for it he would do
the hot potato
but he also remember when Bernie Mac did
def def jam and he did that and they
play the music that's basically what
Boone did is like oh you're saying Boone
rifts Bernie Mac how dare you inspired
[Laughter]
Bernie Bernard
who's the guest Bernard Bernard Mac
Bernard Macklin who's the guest that
you've had on the most on this show
could be you guys David's our fifth
appearing three we've run out of things
to talk about was your first one
yeah hundred 150 200 250 now 300 spirits
do you think there will be a 350 Jays
got to be on a lot Vic Jays been on a
bunch he might be the most do you have
an expiration date those randomly
hey come to my enter with me okay cuz
I'm like doing it and it's like he's
there it's like just [__] join in
do you have an expiration date for this
podcast are you working towards
something no it's just 500 and then I'm
gonna spot that's when I lose interest
and then he doesn't do any more cuz he
lost interest I think he's back
he claimed but I don't know if he real
aunch t' it's tough when you don't see
any gains in it you know that's a
problem that's a hard part you got to
keep figuring out how to get at some
point you're like hey so like early on
you just learn how to make a joke with
it works and you're like hell yeah that
can drive you for a month just to
getting a first bit to work I remember
when I was doing the open mic I was like
if I can just be as good as these
employees you guys yeah if I can just
get as good as them then I'll be happy
for the rest of my life I realize you
guys weren't that great I just sucked
really bad and then you realize that how
many more levels there are to jump up
and then eventually you know once you
get the recognition it was just like oh
if somebody that has power just likes
one of our scripts I would be happy with
that and then eventually it comes down
to like money and then it comes down to
more money I need to be paid more money
for this still gotta earns yeah it's
just never ending never ending when
people say have the idea of making it oh
he's made it no what do you think that
means cuz I know a lot of guys want
sitcoms and then eventually at day jobs
but if you're not sick I'm like you made
it man you made it and then it's like
from the outside that's what it appears
I think making it is just having some
sort of sustainable run but it's like
that's that's really what it is to me to
making it it's like now it's like oh I
don't really have to worry about money I
can do this thing and live poorly but
like poorly for a long time for a long
time I think you can't say you've made
it until you're you're on your deathbed
and you've had a long run and you go hey
I made it but I think that's the thing I
mean it's show biz but just in general
is that everyone always wants more so
it's like you know Johnny Depp is like I
need to do better
you know everyone want to keep go thats
why they don't take breaks was like i'll
be out of hollywood no one will remember
yeah and it's like in here no going in
you don't know going in but it is like
it's just such a a peak in [__]
valley career and there's an expiration
date especially on stand up
feel like at some point you have to make
it bigger at some point you can't go in
there and do a 12:30 spot when you're 45
well that's it's done so this is about
exam because I just stayed in a bunch of
hostels but like but like it's it's a
young person thing to do
yeah you know when you're 25 you can
have roommates even at at 25 that's fine
but at 55 to have roommates is like it
just nothing it's weird it's just you
just can't do it anymore yeah sad yeah
you don't want it it's be on set it's
that you don't want it yeah you have to
have it you got to figure something else
out
that's the other they ate it with each
new decade of your age
yeah like 20s is fine you can do
whatever the [__] you want yeah 30
getting your [__] together and like
finding a way to make a living in this
town and then by the time you're 40 like
you better be established in some aspect
yeah yeah cuz at some point I mean dawn
always reminds me of this Paris where I
was like he pushes it to what I said
more than I did but he was like I said
he says that I I go you know if you ever
made it by now you'll never make it
you'll never be anything
he was look at you now you're doing fine
I was like no I meant like if you
haven't already been on sitcoms or in
movies you can't be like a giant star
you just can't be yeah there's no like
we're known at 30 to look at Leslie
Jones though 48 right but the reason you
know her is because she's the one of the
handful of people it's ever happened
yeah it's rare it's possible it's
possible but I think it also rare it
gives to even be true Carrie sighs if
you haven't brought the problem to is
like I'm a late bloomer in general so it
takes me a little while to figure things
out but then once I figure it out things
will work out but the problem is if you
figure [__] out with your 45 it's
[__] too late I need Dangerfield that
in real late they always point to Rodney
Dangerfield but he was in black and
white man so like he's not the best
example he'd also been doing comedy for
years before that like in he went to him
it's you're talking about 1970 as your
real last yeah what happens yeah it's
rare it is very rare now Rodney
Dangerfield became huge Leslie's big but
she's not like huge I mean sort of speak
dude she she said hi I think barristers
today but we were in the kitchen scared
behind him patted his back and he goes
oh hey man and then I said Leslie and
then I was like wait until she left now
when you said hey man
she says you mean and then some we were
with was like no no some girls like I
get called man sometimes Mike I don't
think that's what Don meant she
six-foot-two I didn't recognize her I
just felt a pat and saw a tall person
this guy did today I'm meeting with a
woman and a man and then he left he's
like seve dudes later really yeah she
was like seed both but she was a woman
whose lady she wasn't like I didn't mean
any offense by it was early in the
morning of dudes yeah that's fine so
yeah at some point though it becomes
like less able to do these things to
live like a slob to live on enough it
just get it gets harder it's harder and
harder and it's dating in LA it's very
hard it starts too big with the girls
like yeah cause like like wait why
haven't you done it
yeah with eight with a game in college
or high school it's like whatever it was
cool and then as I got older I realized
he was a loser but he those things that
made him a loser at 25 didn't apply at
20 yeah you know no no wanting a career
it's like well you know she shouldn't
want a career at 20 it's it's not
learning and stuff but like right with
girls and it becomes like hey that was
fine then just [__] you about my dating
profiles I've seen no aspiring any you
know like anything well like if you're
aspiring I don't oh we want no interest
in like no that's an LA thing yeah LA
has a lot of aspiring somethings
musicians actors your yeah writers
yeah the good thing about writing is the
average age of a new writers guild
member is like thirty six or seven yeah
the same as the PGA this takes a while
to get you know that's the thing people
ask me like do you do writing and I was
like now but I used to be a shooter I
would I would what'd you shoot her yeah
classic see you're like yes of course
I'm a writer we need to do a lot like do
you have a word on your computer because
I could send you the script one of these
days we need to do a live reading of it
we should do a lever at this door who
would play shooter who's your idea I
could I could get up I could get a show
where we do a library
being a shooter too long it's a whole
squid so it'd be how long it takes to
read it but they do it right Minh does
it how long does it take to read of a
full length probably take the same
amount of time 90 minutes yeah yeah with
jokes about it and stuff with you stow
you I oh my god Ari what the [__] wheat
why would this be your law or you want
to do it that way yeah ooh ooh our show
to our show yeah we could do that I mean
you're gonna have to keep like we could
probably just on the opening page spend
like Jeff and I 15 minutes just checking
on that so we would have to be like we
just have to take it scene by scene
couple jokes and move on I could do that
here's what I'm thinking in terms of our
crazy money for so we could do a live
show on charge money that should be a
special
yeah dude shooter and then you have
someone animate like some of the [__]
great that's not like a whole movie it
could be a shooter special but I could I
could uh we could charge tickets have
people there yeah and then maybe more
quarter put out as a podcast get another
couple grand for like a monster a up
dude
and that would pay for like your flights
or something it's a New York I'll do it
and we come in as professional
screenwriters that we are and we
critique where you may have got wrong
how about October I'm up for here to do
it October I'll be done promoting what
do you promote it your specialty in a
plug out or special plug it on your own
ago
Oh unmet eyes got special thanks thank
you
oh really awesome wow that's uh you know
we've asked for special things before at
other things we've never got it review
from your special digs that we never got
it you do you've always been I mean the
bridge is burned there's no bridge dude
you've always been great to us wait
honestly
let me try pause this so you can tell me
special bags been great that's what I
want to say I'm just kidding
we're you know what we were compensated
in other ways that were actually better
because you can't pay your rent with a
special things to that
that uh what was the video we did was a
cult the happy Valentine's Day
yeah happy [__] Valentine's Day 5
million hits on Facebook inside like
three weeks yeah
and they gave you guys how much 300 yeah
I think these I think 200 yeah 250
yeah wouldn't you put your name on there
and then and then the we're gonna do it
like hey we love the fact that we got 6
million hits can we do something like
that again and it was like yeah but you
got to get those guys like writing
credits cuz they didn't get any out of
it other than 200 ebooks and like policy
we can't and I was like and I just
yelled him for a while and I was like
okay well I'm not gonna do it then yeah
and then they change the policy and then
we did one for Steve Rannazzisi did
write writers credit you yeah great
Steve Steve panini baby valley really
yeah and then they finally gave us but
what were we talking oh special thanks
oh I'll put that on my was a the e true
Hollywood story The Comedy Store where I
spent [__] two months getting footage
from cuz I was working oh are you really
yeah I was working I sound book at the
time with ik trying to try to figure out
all this all the clips they had all the
tapes they had is my job to like get him
write them down what's on them and then
digitize them before and by the way when
you played him on the high eight machine
that had a mission would just eat it so
you just stand there watching with a
screwdriver ready to go so we're like we
got to stop it like no no no I pull out
these [__] priceless tapes hey hey
they pay me for fifty weeks but I was
like but I was like can I get another
height machine it's gonna cost or to fix
this Wisconsin
cost $150 to get a new one it's one
hundred one hundred seventy-five no
it fixes will cost 75 to get a new ones
130 something like that and they were
like nah now I just use the one you have
we're not gonna do either like they're
eating tapes of Jim Carrey's first time
onstage yeah yeah that's Comedy Store
back then you know what the weird thing
is because I used I remember watching
the true Hollywood story of The Comedy
Store of my apartment in Chicago really
and I was like oh [__] I gotta go there
yeah and it's so weird that you had a
hand in it it's weird when you come out
here and then you put so what I did this
is not happening Tommy Chong was on
there and so my dad involved
Raisa used to have a theater and big
acts would come through their third
Chicago to do like a one-nighter yeah
Steve O'Neal and Tommy Chong and chief
Cheech and Chong used to come through
there a lot and I asked Tommy Chong
about that theater and he goes I was
just thinking about that theater the
other day he's like what a great place
no way and I was like how crazy is that
like you know you're a little kid you
hear the tales and he's like you're
funny middle of nowhere was it you met
yeah he also was on that show was Drew
Carey and uh Kevin Smith both of whom we
delivered groceries I told Jim I told
drew Cara's like when I used to live her
groceries by the way you're a god
because you're the biggest tipper and
everyone loves you he goes and then he
was telling me he's like that's awesome
he goes I met someone else
who worked there once she's like this
big improv chick and he said that she
got him as the order and literally the
tip that he gave her helped her pay her
rent that month because it was due and
she was short he's like she literally
kept me in my [__] apart now that's
cool
that we talked about that one episode
150 yeah yeah 100 that was the first one
he's like that across the board I've
heard a tipping he said he talked to Sam
Simon and Sam Simon's like what do you
tip limo drivers and he told him he goes
oh no you got to hit more cuz then you
can do whatever you want and no one will
ever tell your secrets and he goes after
that I was tipping double what he told
me to do and I was really fired I'm just
saying like nobody talk you know what
people you know tip people talk [__]
about you
for Drew Carey and also just a great guy
in general he seems like it man he was
just like he's like I have the money
who cares in my eyes he can like he
could commit very heinous crimes and I
would just be like I would defend it and
Kevin Smith too great and he was on that
show too
that's I didn't have a chance to talk to
like as I was coming off stage he was in
the waiting room and then he was like
good job and that was it I wanted to
stop and be like yeah like a best tipper
he had like.he bars I give a stupid over
there he bought Ben Affleck's old house
um and so he he had a balcony like right
above his door and I was delivered to
him and he comes out on the balconies
hey and I looked up and he was I holds I
forget what the amount of money was he's
like Dragic
[Applause]
lower a bucket no II just I just leave
it there what is the door broken I think
he was probably bigger at the time and
it's probably editing or so yeah you
like going down there right then fat you
mean yeah a little fatter and uh yeah
and he just threw the money down to me I
had to like track it I saw in Yangon my
first my first like my second night
their second day a third day someone was
like low I'm from a six-story some old
lady lowering a bucket with money they
take it out put whatever stuff in there
and she pulls it back it's [__]
awesome zip it happy to hybl the guy I'm
gonna start doing that but yes I live in
the second floor did you put a bucket
bucket in the bunk what did you put like
a baby in there as a joke I'm here no
are you lobby no go back outside go back
outside yeah there's a bucket coming
down for you how long are we take a dump
of the bucket don't take a dump right on
that bucket
Oh would have been great because you
could or you could have been out of the
country by the time she got it up to the
sixth floor
dude you should literally you should
[__] in a sock though but use it as like
I like a homey don't play that remember
when he had that homey Bopper but it's
just [__] you just smack people in the
face we hated doing stand-up after that
cuz people would just yell homie all his
lines from he quit for a long time
sprays is the worst he didn't come to
the store he didn't come to the store
for years when he first came back Tommy
Morris the infamous talent coordinator
what he was like I forget what he was
doing was like they even did a set and
Eleanor's like hanging around in the
front of the store where the booth is
yeah Tommy Morris looks to Damon Wayans
he's like people don't want to see it
talked to the crowd okay what I scolded
him and as a legend they were movie
stars who is this guy imagine being told
that Saturday Live In Living Color movie
star they did we got fired and that's
why it went over to in living color the
TV show we had for years
yeah and he's [__] funny yeah he's
just funny and you come gave you advice
on celebrities hasn't been there for
years
so hey let me just she's also cool is he
cool guys you see Jason Connor class now
damon wayans i don't know if that's true
buffalo we tried to have Tommy thanks to
Damon Wayans and I gotta get paid on
there but we tried have people in
Buffalo on the case they said they have
not been able to track him down David
Taylor linked me up with his in Buffalo
they would be they would know about it
if there's a comedy class yeah man I'm
the TA up there that'd be great if he
was Jimmy Pig teachers assistant there
he said it squashed my beef there Wow
how do you think I made stars in
Hollywood you're gonna listen to me or
play with your balls oh [__] oh you lost
control dude the fire's gone buck wild
on Rogue Ari's on fire did you use what
are you doing you're using that stick
dude it's gonna break you're using like
a spaghetti noodle to move the logs
around you guys wanna pause or keep
talking about well talk amongst we'll
talk amongst ourselves talk about re
shorts he's been wearing those every day
that I've seen him have you washed those
when he first got to LA he were watching
twice for like three weeks still has it
he was wearing the red shirt the other
day you know bad the pits of that shirt
smelled was it was it looka whatever it
was it was the shirt he's wearing every
day for three weeks I think he still has
it because I look Kevin Kristi commented
is that the shirt they used to wear all
that yeah it is it's the shirt dude he's
been camping in those he's been [__]
the red salmon
he's been [__] his pants those
aren't hiking shorts dude I don't like
golf short all you shoulda shorts I
brought they're really bad you come with
the matching belt oh you bought those
while you're here did it come with the
matching belt yeah
show us your belt it's a red belt now I
know I want to see his new belt you want
to see his binky have I've seen enough
of it it is it is brief time here I've
seen plenty of it could you could you
paint a picture of it to like a
policeman as a sketch you know the
surprisingly though when you do
mushrooms with Ari he's not into antics
like he's surprisingly yeah well that's
pretty good
I'm a you are on my bat by like your
your great I got a new roommate mentor
that's what I got annoyed with you in
Montreal the infamous [__] cast that
would never be aired Dennis but here I
do a podcast not the money but for the
promotion
you dialed it in dude you weren't giving
me anything you admitted your television
tell me the line that you told me that
said heating me anywhere you were just
sitting there going like let's go that's
gay
let's get into something dude I said
that you should have taken off your
clothes and got in the shower I was in
the shower
it wasn't oh you were the shower with
your clothes on yeah I should've taken a
dump of the instrumental podcast and
you're not airing it and that's [__]
I took time out of my day to [__] do
an Emmy here's the quote though me tell
me tell everyone the quote that you told
me which is why I said we should not
which probably not era it was
embarrassing you were saying over and
over again this can't be as good as your
normal episodes because I know what you
guys Ryan wasn't there if Ryan was there
would have been better and then put me
over the edges oh yeah because then we
would have while your odd the toilet
there's all kind of area da post you're
vulnerable I don't have time but that
was your only way you would do I have to
take 20 minutes take a dump why don't we
do it while I'm doing that
oh and so then we'll put me over and you
see a man on the side of this sidewalk
in need yeah and you became Mother
Teresa - this man are you on mushrooms
and the guy was a need and you've
treated this man with so much respect
this guy who could have been a molester
Friday probably wasn't but he could have
been anybody yo you should have done
with shrooms before the podcast and then
he would have treated with the utmost
respect yeah and so I said this guy look
at this guy some guy in the street with
his pitch rugs Ari Shaffir treats them
with the respect ever if what's he do to
me hey vis me no put me through the
wringer just like thinking about
slapping food rats on his hands if you
don't know them you doesn't work then
it's just mean but you did other
podcasts that week and I don't think any
of them were [__] can cuz I didn't
believe in any of them I didn't believe
in them you I believed in you help this
man with shrooms you did bring him out
of the ether I'll give you that he was
gone and when you brought him back can
we hang out I know that we're not gonna
hang out man but I'll get your water
you're like I'll get you a lift or I'll
get you home and he's like no you want
to hang out he was like [__] like no
no you know you're pushing the limits
but he brought him back he would do this
guy I couldn't talk and then he heard
someone say something about wrestling
and he perked up and he came back alive
cuz always like you're gonna come out of
this I can tell she's a bad place to do
shrooms in it's
downtown Montreal I've been there alone
though who knows I think he was with
friends for what I remember this show it
just seemed like a it seems like the
worst any its interior of a city seems
terrible I'm posting a nasty show this
year I know why put a word in for me for
next year why do people do shrooms to go
to a show is that a good idea
it's cuz I know what it is because I
talk about mushrooms a lot no I know but
is that a good idea it's not a good idea
yeah it's not unless you take like a cap
or something but people like we're gonna
[__] if it's like you that's fun for
Grateful Dead yeah
bands music festivals when you're out
super you sit there
you're just confined and you there's
nothing is more so you're not following
along really with the jokes
it's just like if you watch Adventure
Time but not have you ready no comma
show not mine somebody tossed out
because they couldn't stop laughing like
it was just uncontrollable laughing no
I'm asking you because you have more
people that show up yeah well the first
time I realize well the first bits I did
about it was was on the monsters tour
with Tripoli and rouse and Neff I forgot
yeah yeah and somebody was laughing so
hard and then someone else was screaming
yeah it was I think that's what it was
it was like they'd laugh and then one
guy would scream and the next he was
like the worst rimshot by the way I
totally agree with you now you got a
blast-off right from the get-go it it
was good but it would have been even
better if just a pure blast off in Banff
and it's just moment [__] [__] [__] it's
yeah lose control they'll take a little
bit more that Pete always says it's like
no blast off then take a little more but
I did blast off at later and then I that
was good yeah it's fine to the point
where if I did cuz I didn't go cuz you
guys didn't so I was like I'll come back
well I would have blasted off if you got
if everyone's gonna blast off but then I
got peak out in my head think I'm taking
that whole bag I said I took a third of
it what's the time please [__] go for
it for your go for the great was
everybody how long does it take in your
system to hit yeah 32 two minutes to an
hour
what if you shove them in your butt pipe
much quicker let's try it I don't know I
put some in just a minute ago I was
inside getting the poker you ate some
mushrooms
my butt okay but yeah but the blood will
dilute it how's your ass bleaching doing
I haven't seen it since the bleaching
you ever looked at it there's no
before-and-after picture right then but
I haven't seen it like late I don't know
if it lasts Seder if we was just like
ready these II really got in there
spreading those chilies for those to do
all by the way if you I mean the way
that you handle your hygiene those butt
cheeks are just caked on the sides and
everything with duty no white man no
dude I don't yeah but you have a lot of
servicemen Lud yeah I don't know I
wouldn't touch you outside outer cheeks
so you better go play with your ass yeah
one girl lick my butt and it was almost
like did she kill herself did she want
to kiss you and you're like no no just
seems like a stupid thing to do don't
get fancy let's just do it the
traditional so now okay so the careers
whatever at first you come you're
20-something how old were you guys when
you got here I was I was 25 23 you were
25 it's harder you know what I look back
if I was like if I came out as a teen I
would literally just be like early 30s
and I'd be in a good place
yeah it's tough though 18 no Kyle you
know it's a tough plus figuring [__] out
it's just uni life in general 18 tough
how do you pay rent you knows a lot yes
it would have been difficult you get a
shitty job just like you did you would
be but then also do you really want to
spend here that's money you want to
spend those years out here as opposed to
just [__] around and then a lot of
the guys we know who didn't go to
college and just did stand-up like have
a period where they act out like kind of
crate you know like they're living
college when they're like 28 right as
opposed to or two we literally live like
we're [__] of high school you're not
no I'm a gentleman we all live like you
okay you want to go do this
realize that for the last I don't know
how many years maybe 12 years I have not
had a table you would think this guy
like you look at his place you would
think that somebody had just robbed it
of a minimal of like artwork
and furniture barely any silverware
minimalism man he'll only buy what's for
sale in his apartment building like
people that are selling stuff on the
cork board and by selling you mean leave
it there for ya put it in my place but
you know what when I when I was doing
those shrooms a couple weeks ago or
whatever last week I really thought you
know what this is a pretty good [__]
life well that's a thing it really is no
matter what we're doing nothing that's
fun
yeah and but you're getting by even the
fact like having a good time writing
jokes a stupid [__] and that I was like
I don't have a house a wife or kids and
then I was like holy [__] it's I I could
literally just go move somewhere if I
wanted to and just start a new life cuz
I don't I'm not I have nothing tough in
terms of jobs cuz we're so far out on
the limb of they're like wait what are
these oh yeah but I'm save you what the
tile and they'd be like what you don't
grow trees he will now be the president
of our company where he met somebody
yeah he's like you know in my country I
am a doctor oh this is my country I said
to glaze don't know it's tough when you
meet a guy who's like I was an engineer
and you're like and he's driving either
like lifts or you know you're like man
I've never met somebody like that I have
yeah we have it's rough the guy drove us
in Buffalo yeah he's like I was like the
top neurosurgeon like a yeah we were
like what the [__] can I move to him
like Lebanon or something get work yeah
I forget I think he's an Indian but this
town always keeps you like just when
you're ready to quit you go holy [__] we
just got to just got a good-paying gig
it throws you enough morsels we're like
it's the what's the line that Tommy
morsels the line the guy from Bruce
Springsteen's band mocked and Sopranos
just when you think they're right you're
out they keep pulling you back yeah it's
from the Godfather oh there you go oh
[__] now like now our careers actually
taking off we were talking with comedian
hey-zeus Trejo I think who's had some
recent success I just got put on
varieties list to watch yeah
what is he done that he's got that he
did Montreal last year he's doing
Montreal this year too but we were
talking to him and how like in stand-up
and just in LA you just you fit you're
like oh I'm at my rock bottom but then
like a month later you're like oh I
wasn't even close yeah exactly like
something wait words just came around
the back yeah you know what that's why I
always liked I had it it's always gonna
hit you harder yeah and you're like oh
no I'm it's all up and oh by the way
when you think you're done with the
shitty times also right back in yeah oh
yes and that's why you but you know what
you survived that and then you're like
oh yeah I'm ready for it it's the people
that get success early on they can't
handle it and I was like I could handle
it if everything around he's like well
how do I do it yeah everyone else deal
with it exactly the our saving grace but
also something that nurse has that have
been to our detriment is that there's
two of us yeah what so like you have
people to rely on when one of us is down
usually the other is up so it's like a
balance yeah but what hurts is that like
we never really networked because we
always had each other and also are
people like oh they're out there like
their own thing so like they don't need
and there are times we were like we
would be making a good living if there
was just one of us it's just like barely
enough to get by for two of us yeah
when Taylor and I were writing I
remember going like that like you know
that you'll have to split the writing
like money and we're like well how much
does writing money like oh my thirty
five hundred a week like oh yeah we can
do this that's ten times what we're
making now raised yeah yeah and you get
accustomed to a certain level of living
I think you are - so once you get money
you're like I have like this is like the
dolly I need it I don't need it exactly
I broken swords you got a baller karmic
for what from New York that's just a
burden or do you talk it's just a waste
of money yeah but it's a good rappers
head around it though I think in me has
a desire for that it's not like I'm like
I don't think I should it's like I don't
think about it it really is I tell you
about the chandelier yeah yeah the
chandelier well like my aunt has these
Chihuly's is like glass maker the
hardest JW who like that but like
they're super expensive the chandeliers
are very nice but it was like get that
if you have money but he's like I don't
have any I don't
he thought I don't want a chandelier me
no I know I don't want a [__] car I
want to take a trip around the world so
I do that when I just buy a bag of
diamonds it's like you know it's like
you're just by car is like you're like I
want to I'd rather travel you know let's
say you need a car but he couldn't wrap
his head around it because he told me
about this one's good he's like he
doesn't get it's like a it's like having
a Disneyland ride that you can drive
whenever you want
it smells like yeah I don't think he's
just not that into Disneyland yeah well
you can just go to Disneyland like what
you know like whatever I can get the
season pass or you can rent it but also
you got a car guy if I had money I
wouldn't car would be low on all I would
get would be a car and that wouldn't
spend all so if you get to a point where
like you haven't had money and you just
don't buy anything then when you get
money you're like I don't need I don't
want to buy any haven't made these taste
for myself yeah I'm kind of like this
way minimalist nice why Asians are good
students because we get to college like
wow the Asians are lapping us I can't
because they've been studying since they
were [__] one
yeah you've just learned how to study
now so it gives you're paying or you're
like still trying to you know yeah so
you're still trying to figure out a cram
and make there already of all you're
trying exactly so it's like I we've
evolved to the points like we just don't
need anything well there's this big push
for minimalism I was like I've been
living like that for 15 years ahead of
our time the problem with me and O'Neill
too is most people we know never like
most comics don't work and we've worked
what do you mean work day job like it
work a day job or something which makes
it so hard like especially for us just
in terms of time and being able yang
[__] yeah because you think you have a
job that's good enough to pay you to
survive but shitty enough where they
don't care if you take a ton of time off
we're gonna be the next three months off
yeah daddy knows best or something or
whatever yeah so it's it's a hard
balance but most comics for whatever
reason either get family money or well I
think a lot there's a lot of family
money like in people that come out here
who are like oh yeah I don't feel like
oh I don't know you've never had a job
and you're also not working in the
industry I don't know what you've been
doing over there guys who have like
new-car you're like what is well so and
so do from yani that's why agents and
stuff to be an agent to be an assistant
agent or manager has been assistant
manager and you make when I started at
William Morris is 450 a week you started
know when I start here oh sorry I'll get
paid 450 a week they
made em work overtime they didn't get
paid for overtime oh that's why they
sued yeah so it's 450 weeks salary and
then and then like well who can survive
that like white people who have rich
parents who are getting the money yeah
that's why the industry is that because
it's like you have to just be paid you
have to have this like cushion it's it
just or it's gonna take you twice as
long because you're like you can only
put half as much time into it right
because you have to be doing this job
job now I was in when I was in Hong Kong
and Shanghai and doing stand-up out
there they didn't have a they didn't
understand why all these American comics
had to be broke they're like it's a
night job to be stand-up I know that's
so why would it just exactly 75 grand a
year your day job and then also do the
stand-up that's why when I hear guys
living in their car I go why why you go
to your car because you don't you only
perform for 10 minutes at night like
what are you living in your car for you
could go out get a job you're also
you're not writing for 8 hours a day
yeah so just go get a job there's I
don't like the romanticism of like I'm
living in my car it's like no you're
just lazy yeah yeah there's a lot but
then there's there are some guys who are
like they believe like even getting a
day job there's gonna take away but it's
like you have to survive it's like you
can't else a day job gives you way more
material and you're like interacting
with in day-to-day life like they were
dude there was a period where dudes were
living in the comedy store and it's like
just go get a job just go get a job but
we know I never we're both me and him
were like we would both rather work [__]
jobs than live in like the Comedy Store
hostile situations where there's like 18
guys in a studio apartment then they
live with PJ that's rough man I just
couldn't not you get to the adrià I
don't want to do that right it's just
becomes you just can't do it yes we wake
up next to you see some guy with a
[__] boner and his bunk but wherever
you're living it's Jake also it's all
it's good enough yeah like I'm Pro
tching 30 a kid dude I had a roommate I
couldn't do it anymore
just to cheap rent and I was like I
gotta live alone I always liked women
though that had good jobs what do you
mean it was always nice house did they
paid for you or you know I wouldn't I
they would be like I'm like look I can't
afford to go there like all right well
yeah I'll take you I'm like all right
but that there's a shelf life on the
romanticism of like oh I'm dating an
artist
it's like dating a guy who doesn't but
you know what no here's the thing you're
only a deadbeat if you're not working
like we worked when we were learning to
write and writing we were writing seven
days a week for like hours on end so
they see that and they're like okay he's
actually yes he's not just sitting
around
he didn't like cause like she would hear
some of the stuff she's like I'm hearing
fart sounds like yeah we're writing yeah
we're like this is part of it yeah but
it sounds like she didn't leave me
because of that
no I know but I'm just yeah yeah yeah
there was she was too close well that's
the problem you can't write in a
one-bedroom when you're living with a
woman when you're ripping farts to the
outsider did sound like not like time
foolery but that's her writing about the
fart vapors unlock the creativity within
the brain that must be tough APUs in
terms of writers rooms like what farts
I'm sure oh dude they're filth no but
I'm saying like there's awful woman with
you if there's women with memories
there's women on staff it's like you
need that he was like you need the
presence of a woman because otherwise it
gets too much like that but when you
don't have the presence of woman you
can't allow yourself to like how about
this you just show your nuts yeah like
you you just can't
and then whatever comes out of that well
might not be good but that you can't get
that if there's a woman there's yeah
what's the dude Harris twiddles was that
it's the guy's name
yeah I guess he showed his donger a lot
when he was on that Sarah Silverman show
I can't you know if she was around yeah
and I guess everyone was all right I cap
icture of them and put it in her book
the dick yeah yeah and he was like
obvious and he was like Oh what he was
alive yeah yeah and he was like you know
it's weird because she told me had to
keep our relationship a secret
and then without my permission she just
published a picture of my dick and so
I'm supposed to keep it a secret but
then she can say here's Harris whittles
dick just seemed kind of wrong but I
guess I'm in a lower position so I can't
really say anything that seems really I
know there's a difference between and
women but still it's like publishing it
you seem like that's like worse than you
know it's pretty bad
I'm sure to fill the time it's pretty
tough than your but you know that no
comic is gonna sue you because it's just
bad street cred for them so they're like
you're pretty much at the mercy of
everybody well then you have to be like
if you if you sue then it makes it seem
like you're like you think you have a
bad Dixie
to be like me all right yeah you're like
I love it it's great wasn't it was his
limp Biskit - right I think it was his
limp oh I don't know I wouldn't want my
limp bizkit shown really to anybody
anybody I agree you want your hard babe
oh no but not published do you know I
actually wouldn't mind I just yeah you I
think you're not on the same page as us
opera Tommy Morris I don't know if you
ever even knew this he would always say
Ari's gay yeah why why do you think I
saw his dick involve so much okay like
because I was on stage and so I said you
were in the jujitsu you got to roll
around with out there guys didn't he say
it because my [__] was so [__] up
that's how you get so Joe used to [__]
me I don't know that's we used to say
that Joe takes him out on the road what
do you think they'd do in those hotel
rooms when they're doing their jujitsu
[__] each other Wow the hotel rooms
Wow
they move the beds out okay yeah Murphy
beds okay they fold them up into the
wall so they can [__] so do you guys
still think about quitting at this point
like it must go through here no I think
I got to the point when she gets so far
into the game we're also gonna go
quitting become so hard but I have so
many other jobs that I'm interested in
yeah like I was gonna become a like a
child a parasailing instructor in India
of course you were so well I don't think
it takes a lot you just going to learn
how to parasail put in a year into that
and then you could probably India in
India
oh okay sorry evidently it's a big thing
over there I saw a ton of this but they
do it right off the side of the road you
just pull your car widths on the road
there'll be a guy there
can you major in it in college I know I
don't think I don't think you need they
go that far do you know what you I mean
like sometimes you have other interests
you go you know what that would be cool
there is that too for sure I have zero
career interests other than writing but
I think as I've gotten older like that
my interest the opportunities have
dwindled so now I'm really buckling down
on this it becomes so hard
I mean Simona you talked with us again
you got I want to quit on equip but then
it's like but then what you can't go
back to being 25 and say I'll be I'll go
to law school no I would never go so
yeah but it's like quit - what there is
no other job waiting you in this long
you drive fan boats in the Everglades
you saw my something like that yeah I'm
talking about like that or like joining
some sort of mercenary group and just
working like how did you write with him
man that's a legitimate people do that
all the spending on the week he doesn't
new he's very whimsical is it new
would your mom's column she said you got
a lot of farts in your head so it
depends on like what it is and sometimes
it's the helicopter pilot other times
it's another venture yeah opening an
ultra-light Airport what I would just
man that yeah I'm giving rides like you
know ultralights
they're like open no carts like it just
a tube frame you know with Drakon fabric
like that yeah you know and then you're
not gonna get a lot of busy you can't
but maybe if you opened it up to like
drug cartels that are flying like using
ultra lights to transport drugs they
would probably give you a decent amount
to just look the other way something
like that would look the other way yeah
I would let them just land there and
then just be okay you can use this as a
drop off point for like ultra lights to
come in here we're shipping like I'm not
interested make sure the pavements good
I remember watching on good much
Breaking Bad probably two years ago
maybe that worries
no I'm good I had a big one I remember
why burn my first a little bit okay
kindling watch watching Breaking Bad and
it was like working these [__] jobs it
was like maybe I should just [__]
sell some mess okay with like there are
times where I was like you know the
chance of getting caught are slim to get
caught sup for selling drugs like you're
watching your show like that and you're
like [__] good all this cash just you
know using to go to some [__] yeah but
then have you ever been wanted by like
either people that like a group of
people are trying to beat you up or the
cops it's very it's of a very anxiety
inducing thing that works the fireplace
hooker like if you ever lost your master
right if you ever lost your hand you
would do very well with like a hook hand
thank you the way you
use the head maneuver that thing around
you'd be able to masturbate with a hook
ooh ooh talk about a bloody ass you've
one bad wipe with a hook head your fee
would tear you would shred that you have
to hook a doctor what happened another
wife situation yeah what do you think
look at the hook in the blood put two
and two together cholesterol I burst one
of the hemorrhoids bursts popped it like
a balloon who's like I'm trying to think
of like who's gotten out and been okay
but I mean who's like for me the biggest
tragedy I saw getting out was the
infamous Jim painter who we've talked
about yeah just you need it though - he
anybody needed - yeah just so good yeah
I try to think of other people who you
see leave and you're like man if only
base but do you have do you have like it
do you want to do this forever
I don't know but it's like I don't I
mean what do you mean like if I was a
vampire I could live just in all time
like the rest no I mean do you buy do
you anticipate dying or liver they go
they go I don't want to die that's what
they mean yeah so it's like they think
oh this is not gonna end for me it's
like if I do something else them how
I'll be younger yeah but it's not like
that you're still gonna die I'd like to
be out by like 60 but I have a like and
then go completely off the grid like
done with society and just living off
like I have a farm a couple hundred
acres and then just spend the time like
adding some of the rally car track that
I have there and like building more
bunkers and stuff once our buddy John
little had enough of O'Neill's musings
angry little adventure at that time was
he wanted to sail around the world you
think you're gonna sail around the world
O'Neil you're [__] you're one of
those [__] that sounds like that
sounds like little but then I realized I
didn't like yeah I don't like the water
that much so I was like what am I
thinking but what I would like to do is
take an ultra-light around the world
I love ultralights since I was a little
kid I've been obsessed with ultralights
involve like a good chance of death
O'Neal probably is not gonna be that
into it is adrenaline what's so what's
I'm the opposite what's the path that
people ask like you you're not doing as
well as you would have liked or you
deserve well you know what those things
are things are looking at I'm looking up
we have a thing going now we don't want
to talk about it yeah we don't wanna
jinx that but that will be really good
for us jinx so okay and then what we
have the novice knockers show that we're
trying to get going you could check out
it I'd be good on Facebook its knockers
the TV show if you hear it sorry is it
Ari's constantly poking the fire is what
you hear yeah it's really obsessive
about it I want to burn every last like
inch of the [__] wood did you have a
though you always yes where did you burn
[__] a lot in camp sleepaway camp we
like draw Lysol with our names and
cursive and you light it up and the
whole name would come fire and the
people the counselors like you can't
light dry wooden bunks on fire trust me
it's not good I live off like 15 camos
once and somebody's like someone of that
had to go to talk to the head counselor
or something like that
use like your pyromania pyromania can
owes like what's that it was wheel off
fire I was like oh yeah maybe oh that's
the term for it yeah I guess so then
have you ever burned yourself I mean
like burned like I've singed my
eyelashes and my eyebrows and everything
from I threw a can of gasoline you know
I would never do that I drank a saline
really as a foyer to be a fire blower I
think I like the smell was just dominant
right I do love the smell ugh I said to
the winces poison on it no yeah like in
the garage and I said to my parents
years later is like you took me to get
out like my stomach pump right now like
now I think I would have been a lot
smarter if I hadn't I worked in a lot of
enclosed areas where like I was
constantly breathing in diesel fumes and
pesticides like non-stop I burned a lot
of brains the question you asked a
minute again the path people asked that
a lot
so how do you do it but there's like
there's eight billion different ant yes
my answer is always and it's kind of a
dark answer is like it's like wandering
through the woods you know there's you
can get out somewhere but if you take a
left it may lead you way further into
the woods you don't know I mean writing
has been like our bread and butter but
also I've gotten to I was like I would
like to I'd like to do an hour of
stand-up just to say that I was here
like an hour like good like a really
good and just go I was here I did this
and I did it well and then if I continue
what maybe it may be then you know a lot
of people just do like an hour and they
go oh [__] take some 10 15 years do an
hour and then after that they're able to
just do an hour every year yeah once you
once you've done something yeah out of
like we created at that point and doing
that this is not happening I was like oh
there's so many things that are possible
I can do [__] I could do T you know I
could do a TV yeah because you held your
own
yeah as a CO yeah it's not my manager
got me a bunch of general meetings with
some networks sometimes she goes and
which I don't pitch anything just just
me with saying hi I talk about sports
whatever and then it was like wise I
just want you to know that these are
regular people yeah that this thing you
have in your head is a calm restore guy
of like oh I can't do that it's like why
they weren't college right when you were
starting and it's like it doesn't
there's there's no mystique to them
they're just dudes no it's true yeah I
think a lot of I mean TV show is like
yeah the story I worked on and then I
just I did it again but there were
cameras there that time and it's just
confidence literally just but a lot of
times people to get into stand-up don't
have any confidence because that you
know your whole life you were [__]
well there's that too
and so then it takes a while to get to
the point where you like yeah I can do
the same [__] that all these people are
doing it's like that little girl like I
can do anything
yeah smart yeah yeah right some of the
do you have any interest in that flows I
like stand-up I don't know if I've ever
loved it yeah is part of my prom I'd
never like when you're not here you say
like I'm doing like 800 spa and my koala
that sounds a lot I like it and it's
like something I can do but I like it is
like a side mistress I think if you
thought I saw some sort of like a
in there like that's my prime I'm gonna
go do this you need some wins
I have no wins I don't really have even
spots where I can even develop you know
you could but I want to chase what I
writing down well yes this is it's like
what you have to have a reason to try to
chase him down you have to be like oh if
I did like it's okay so I've recorded
three specials now in a CD my next
special double negative is out now what
it this is three weeks from now right
we're calendar on you have a phone yeah
oh yeah may wind up just perfectly seven
nine eight nine nine and then oh so this
we just a 295 oh yeah see you good so
Monday's 96 so you probably watched his
special last week it's out now yeah I
probably wash it ready but like now that
I've done those things if I got all my
spots of store and the stand if they all
dried up I'd be like oh I should go
forget other spots because this will
help me go do another special yeah but
if you guys had all your spots dry out
then I'm like what's the point
no it's very ya know or am I wrong no no
it's true it's true yeah yeah because I
mean you can try to go fish around but I
mean it's hard to develop you need to
have a comedy club audience to develop
at this point yeah like you've already
developed past the open mic err level
and the other stuff but yeah when you
handle an iPhone do you just feel the
power surged through you what do you
want July by the way Rory Scovel Netflix
it's so funny he's great so fun I guess
great everything I was tired there's
some [__] [__] there's never golfed
he's unbelievable oh really he's like a
savant and everything he is that
stand-up but when he yeah he also know
stage he's just like on an oriental rug
and it's just like I don't even know
where it is but it's great and in the
middle of it he goes stay tuned now a
word from our sponsor or something and
then he just cuts to a sketch
oh really and it's special I was like
that's [__] that's like what I would
do is like don't take it so seriously I
like people who are playing with the
Convention somebody you know it's just
like the hours just been done well
that's why I have a double negative
that's what's cool but I also like I
like chelsea peretti kind of playing
like exactly
crowd the crowd shot different stuff
like why not yeah why not exactly right
that's what paletas purple onion was
that - that was a long time ago why not
just dude it like dice did that special
in front of like 12 I would like that
Adam Sandler's first CD was like oh
there's no stand-up on here my thought
of doing an hour would do I wanted to do
this just for shitty Oh our sets and you
put them just together and you don't
even do you just say this is another 15
minutes different crowd well big Jay did
a crowd works CD and I told him like hey
what you want to do is every time you go
up the cellar just pay for the recording
equipment to be there ya have it and
then like you'll make your best and you
make an hour in no time and he was like
now how many centers I want to do it
that way they just want to do like one
recording or two recordings and I'm like
but then you're forcing it instead of
having the great crowd work because
yesterday I want to do it it's like oh
well alright so you got to do what you
want on your own that's why I mean if
you if you just record on your own you
release a CD it's like here's my hour
maybe it's I thought made it's like a 15
minute of just jokes 15 minutes of
[__] with the crowd and then a 15
minute where you're telling some stories
and then like 15 minutes of whatever you
know you could even do the last 15 like
the duo act the Danish and O'Neill up on
stage [__] with people I had that
bonus feature in my last one was just a
Jew na yeah people seem to like that but
nobody saw because they've done a lot of
[__] extra features it could you know
what they did like the extra release the
digital release in addition nobody gets
to special and then and then buys the $5
extra version for the gada
even though it's actually pretty much
50% more it's probably one obsessive fan
a few but I mean like do start about
10,000 people you ready stalkers what
stalkers know like like Ali Wong gets
yeah no no one people that no one's
after that there's that guy that bum
rushed the stage in Calgary was he after
that day yeah that that should happen
sometimes it's a little weird whoo
what's your like if you had to say your
average fan like age sex skin blue one
is white male white donor sure they all
smoke pot this is like not like shroom
er condoms are no condoms the majority
not rumors is that the term Forex rumor
yeah sure there's a shrew might yeah so
doubt what do your parents say about you
guys career
my mom dad knowing died knowing your
failure that was a good one my mom tries
to help and she offers like the hardest
career alternatives ever a game show
like I don't automatically go in there
like this guy's great why don't you do
commercials then I get in and I win and
it's like oh for your participant yeah
no participant and if they just go on a
game show that's see and like you crazy
like you have to get on then you have to
wait a lot my mom's super supportive
because my like my parents never had
real jobs they always like my mom was an
immigrant she's like yeah I don't know
from Germany you know that she came here
when she was like 28
my guess is over I mean that's not true
we don't know that for sure
operators what he was 14 what else is he
supposed to do there's no other jobs
available come from Nazi youth oh dude
that's not true
that not on that not on the blood side
that was in marriage what was his name
Heinrich no I was close to that I think
they had a dog named Heinrich there have
peanut butter we used to bring a peanut
butter no Neela's mom there's a name for
a dog
O'Neill's mom has been like a mother
figure to me encounter he goes all the
time she hosts me for they see has been
great to me but I can sense like an
inner guilt what do you mean no get out
of here you know what you're uninvited
he's not invited versus a Jew what would
it be yeah you know we I didn't tell her
that part she doesn't make me check the
L she said these
you see her kicking him in the cancel
and gretel from which I've heard her say
she obviously had it tough yeah she's
super supportive by the way my everyone
else in my family's lawyers so it
doesn't really matter what I do like
it's a win everyone else is successful
that's why my parents let me date
non-jews where it's like we already have
a bunch of kids from juice oh there's
still all dude of all the things you do
I would have thought that would be like
right that's not even on the radar
anymore who think if I don't know a lot
about wait do they they don't know a lot
we don't know you smeared [__] on your
face other than your brother
probably not you brother listen the
podcast no I think just saw a picture or
something maybe maybe he's doing that
week sit on punch-drunk where the third
week was bleaching my [__]
we drank piss where that was drink my
own piss over ice by the way well bad
was it barely taste it was over the ice
also mostly a clear one yeah so it's
pretty watery yeah what you need is one
of those those thick foamy frothy ones
whether it's still warm over the ice no
no everybody was sitting in there for
like 30 minutes
okay I mean it was cold you have to
drink it right out of the sample Oh half
the trick it wasn't a bet I just [__]
went for it why don't you do piss and
coke or something like mix mix it with
something your question is why don't I
what's your question yeah why don't you
cut it with something have you eaten any
jizz oh yeah I'm have licked it never
tried it no oh no you've tried it as a
kid you don't like let me see what oh
you mean up some old man's jizz
countertop you oh yeah I found a pair of
tighty whities that it's of GZA too but
I licked some your own do you know I've
smelled it it's gotten like stuck to my
nose from something you smell a little
too I'm obsessed with smelling things
like smelling your fingers and smelling
things yeah that's what makes my fiance
smell my fingers and she says get the
[__] out of here yeah that's why I want
to smell your like no one's ever liked
smell my fingers they smell delicious
it's always a bad smell isn't ya no
roses garlic onions chopped garlic I
love that that smell smell it on your
fingers all day all day I I [__] garlic
you [__] garlic yeah it smell on my dick
so you taste yeah if you taste your own
jizz of Cour
you have yeah but have you tasted your
own duty are you is that something that
you maybe your thing about in the future
let's have taste test for duty no it's
not something I think about the future I
thought you're seriously I was like I
don't really have to go but so now what
can you guys see yourselves in the same
position at 50 now what would have to
happen at that point you mean where I am
right now at 52 aside pact at 48 yeah
well based on what happen I'm a year
older than him so I'll be yeah well I
don't know I don't know how it's gonna
work I do like it is enough to life he's
gonna have to kill me and then go on the
run for a year and then when he turns 50
takes himself out that's the fact
yeah but here's the thing though like no
real impact is I think I've buckled down
more now than I ever have and I things
are moving now it's one of those things
where it's like [__] has to go big now
or we're going home going home is like
quitting I don't know what do you do
yeah what is home it's moving like
everyone I know is gone no no what do
you mean there's no home yeah like
there's no just a place to remember my
families are there my family's there oh
I don't even have that like my home town
is done like nobody I know I love you my
friend John Poland like I could I could
say hi to them but it's like yeah we
can't hang out late man we got families
yeah I can see you on weekends like
that's gone I think I would just have
like leave and not even tell my family
and just leave in shame just just where
Europe yeah it's um a third-world
country probably live like a king yeah
like a king on what money I would just
like go to work for a year somewhere we
live like making middle income in a
third world country right now
I guess you're getting by I know so what
were they like where you're white skin
is like oh that will deceive people long
enough yeah maybe we could go to China
where they like hire white guys to wear
suits and just be white metal parties we
almost had my dad go do that to go to
China for like six months
and then was he's like a tall older
white guy and they have you like
impersonate like CEOs of companies and
doctors like announcements you just
stand there really yeah because it gives
him more street cred one guy did it and
it was like the company was like you
and they're like no this guy's our CEO
and he's like no just in it looks like I
did nothing remember they had that guy
who was reading some medical
breakthrough and he they said you're
you're the doctor that did it because we
have a Chinese doctor but nobody will
believe leave that no one cares on
studies they want a white guy older
white guy they can trust it's like a
professional level milli vanilli Wow
also I guess if you want I don't know
you were there and China did people
approach you to go on game shows and
stuff no but I think that happened it's
like a big thing and long enough yeah
that's maybe just go there what's the
allure they just look at the white man
with this is so different I don't know
where they've been like trained I don't
think that where's our society is so
great the commercial of the Chinese lady
with her laundry detergent and she
washes a black dude they're really great
shoves him in he's like no no she was
about to kiss me she shoves him in
headfirst into the laundry machine turns
it on Asian countries are pretty racist
right against black people there gets
everything everybody I mean they're like
a billion of them a way out number
everyone else I heard that was in
Beijing there was somebody one of the
Western comedians that were there small
community purse snatched and they found
him on a subway they found him because
he was black and they called in just
pretty much all the black people in the
city for a lineup and you think I
thought once that's the one yeah if
you're black you might not or even white
and you go to China you might not want
to commit a crime at all you might not
you might not probably not sometimes
jails aren't up to code osha-approved
some tells me our jails aren't that fun
but their jails are definitely not great
probably and you're the only white guy
you can't join any gang there's no white
power yeah but this other thing is
you're bigger than everyone at like if
we went we'd be way bigger there we'd be
like whipping ass they can't get my head
they're not even long enough with their
legs completely stretched out you crazy
they jump up they can almost hit like
the [__] roof oh they all know
couching tiger i think their height has
gone way up to not way up but it has
increased so it's like five seven I
don't know what it is I mean it's gone
up
I'd still gonna dominate in that
Mingo that must have no you can't look
at the tallest one in history is not the
average reason you know Yao Ming is cuz
there's only one and he has bad feet
yeah also that guy's bad feet you're
gonna whip that guy stop foot stop
little foot stomps are good bambam he
that's Eric whoa you have kids cuz that
kid could be like 15 feet tall they told
me yeah mine was one of the only people
big enough like we named to be a
dissenter from the government and was
too big to disappear the people would
notice like what happened to Yama Inc
where's he been they they made sure
every time out against the government a
little bit and they'll be like we got to
let that go but they also were paranoid
about him leaving like his family his
family had to stay there some of they
were worried you would never come back
really and he was like too big of a deal
yeah started up the whole like a league
I think he owns the Beijing team yeah
and they but they didn't want him to
leave and never because a lot of them
get it a snow yeah I'm done dude how bad
I'm here everywhere yeah how bad would
that suck you have all this cash and
everything which the government probably
takes like 80% of all your money all
your earnings and now you have to live
back in China keep a lot what's that
they keep a lot it's all capitalists in
China no you don't think the government
was like we need our cut after you pay
taxes here yeah he was state trained I'd
like to go somewhere where there's no
taxes where that where's that access
[__] what you realize that they own
you here with taxes because at some
point every single person has committed
some sort of tax fraud probably whether
they know it or not and no matter what I
do they could always the government if
they wanted to dig deep on anybody they
could bust anybody for that they got
Capone with tax evasion they can get an
even component Annie but II they own you
this is how the government owns you you
even realize it I think it him on tax
evasion that's crazy
no taxation without representation very
good good quote thank you there's no
freedom if you guys ten years ago how
old were you ten years ago I was in my
late 20s 27 27 28 yeah soon to be 28 it
yourselves now you go hey and ten
if you're in the position you're in
right now would you quit or keep going
that's the 27 year old self that well
you know what I have a way more positive
outlook on things now so I was like I
have a great girl yeah I'm I love the
neighborhood I live in I am I'm doing
okay you know here and there yeah and I
have total freedom I can just [__] go
if you're like you want to go shroom
what yeah exactly the desert I'm like
yeah I don't think I can like what what
do you have going I was just worried
about the shrooming what but this last
time I was like oh [__] now I'm yeah you
like I'm off on the right headspace I'm
like what do you mean because you just
take the TV show and you have a great
girl you got engaged to what what do you
mean yeah and then you already put it on
I think they like you're like things are
going good do I want to possibly throw a
wrench in that's heroin no no I'm just
like are you moving why did you both get
up at the same time I'm moving my chair
and oh is that a oh that's mine never
mind I thought it was a bloody aah
for me it's like it's like when you look
at as a kid you know when you look at
your life you're like oh I'm gonna be
married right a certain but then when
did you go do you think that yeah I
thought so I never I never I summer me
it was never the career you know you set
your life follow a certain timeline
house picket fence all that yeah but
that so it's like when I was 27 if I
thought you told me like where I was now
I pride that I'd be disappointed and
you're saying what you in your cell I
don't know if I would have left just the
situation well you might have been
though also to be like no no but by the
way like your debt-free and you don't
own anything in of total which to me I
think means more now being debt-free and
as debt-free yes completely - it's great
yeah it's that's the only way to get a
little bit of freedom yeah were you like
I don't have to do anything yeah I can
go off the grid at any moment and now
nobody owns me nobody I don't owe
anything to anybody any of you told me
when I was like 14 you'd be I'd be like
at 14 I wanted to be a huge exotic car
dealer it's crazy and now your dream is
to be debt-free
I want it be an exotic dancer
did you really that was another career
my mom actually suggested me not as a
joke not just as an exotic dancer you be
a Chippendale it was like these are real
like that's how she you also have to get
like shredded move you got a baby you
could do it you could do two there's
probably a guy oh there's like 50 washer
the air force Amy of the mail you got to
get those rubber bands so you could tie
your boner off and keep the blood you
need the [__] sock to wear over your
they always got a [__] sock he's just
you just bought a new pair of [__] sock
underwear what do you got your fears or
me undies are you J more the great cuz
that's what you were wearing in the
river when you were pissing no that was
somebody else something something with
that [__] peace out oh yeah yeah yeah
somebody's need a [__] yeah I like it
for hiking it's just as [__] pouch but
they start tearing on the side so it's
like yeah cuz your balls they're like
you can't handle the the mad eyes my
balls are tremendous man I will not list
sit here and listen to you besmirched my
bulb do you remember the comedy store
Gazette that some people wrote that no
one ever knows who did it where they did
a whole thing on your balls how your
balls got repped by UTA and we're having
a bigger career than you were those guys
took a big shot at us and if we can find
out who they said that we were gay we
can find out who did it I'd probably
consider fighting them I would consider
a lawsuit defamation it never track them
down you guys are idiots elusive David
Taylor slippery well so there's no
thought anymore of quitting are they
just like they're always but not like
real felt like it's like it depends on
the day but it's not quitting it's
mostly giving me give it god what am i
doing myself yeah like what's where am I
I think it's more like a giving up like
you know the more you try to push these
projects and you put like sometimes you
put years of work into a you know you
filt you're filming [__] and then it
just doesn't go anywhere and you go how
many more how many more times can I do
this how many more of these do I have in
me [__] can i shovel you're like my back
start nerve I mean we've done pitches
where you're like we've been told in the
room like you you think it's done like
this is exactly
what we need yeah and you're like [__]
that didn't sell I don't know and you
look at the odds of what you have in
favor of who's attached you know like
how like what is it well the more you
realize it's a lottery were you like
this is as good as that or this is
better than that or this is you know and
you go oh all it has to do is like the
right guy looking for something that's
like this it's you realize well yeah I
realize that a certain level you're all
now at the same talent level and the
same work ethic now it just literally
comes down to timing yeah timing oh that
good when they sold Oz the show Oz they
were like oh someone's so heard that HBO
was looking for a prison show and then
someone else like oh I have one thanks
for telling me yeah and it just got
lucky but if he had done it three years
earlier yeah we don't want that to crazy
whatever we've been we've had terrible
terrible luck and timing yeah have you
how do you think it's almost gone except
so like oh yeah look here's an example
and you tell me if you have something
like this we had a movie heartbreak you
know it almost broke yeah it broke us
for like a year and a half like
destroyed art this would just sort of
launched her career ten years ago and it
was like big names attached to big like
we were meet yeah we had a meeting with
Todd Phillips his business guy well no
longer I think he's back in the industry
took a long break it says yeah he's the
guy he's a executive producer of all his
movie he said to us point-blank he's
like and we're like you know we're as
green as a god band and he's like we're
making this [__] movie
you're gonna rewrite this with Todd are
you guys excited and I like I was like
what's going on it's like it was too
overwhelmed like what's happening and
then just completely fell in from that
to like completely fell apart to then I
was rewriting it under another director
for really romani and the worst thing is
people go like if you were talented
enough you would have happened like
nothing now and then you go no it's not
just that that's it that you just hit on
the point cuz it's so hard because if
you go well wait you don't have a house
in the Hills
you must suck suck but you can't prove
that to people at all you're like
sometimes you go people go this is
awesome but no one's buying anything
like this right now like they want
something that's just like this
derivative of this you're getting
executive this like I'm in we're in and
then they go like actually I just got
like halfway through
I got a job offer somewhere else and
then everyone left with the networks
like we're not as excited about is that
guy was these producers who loved
everything we did and we're like and
everything would keep falling apart
really can you get us like represent it
you know like anything they once told us
they go how does it you guys literally
have a armored car just fill this money
man
and we're like yeah well we're like we
need to do a page-one rewrite of this
script we loved for a director for free
this went on for like a year no no top
less and now we rewrote it from scratch
a movie we loved but we made it where it
was good enough it wasn't I don't think
as good as the first one but and then
just nothing and that was like we did it
so fast after it was just so taxing to
be like now what like and then you think
you know you get to the point where like
if we just have a good agent and then
you realize now it's literally just like
you just gotta keep beating the pavement
man that's all it is it literally is
just once you're at a level where you're
writing at a professional level or doing
anything it's literally just staying in
the game long enough and also they
always say if you have a unique voice
that's great but a lot of times when we
submit stuff for TV shows they're like
well yeah these guys aren't gonna mesh
well with what we do we need a guy
that's malleable that we can that could
just adapt with this go into the generic
be - attitude of regular TV so we're
like we have to do our own stuff which
is obviously the hardest thing you could
do but you know we keep doing and
pushing stuff so they asked me they're
like they're like do you write and at
first it was like yeah of course I do
and then now the people ask me it's you
right I'm like no like what do you mean
no I'm like well listen now 15 but times
like 10 years ago I was gonna be a
writer and in comic and then I did it
zero times and I have to be an [__]
to say I'm a good right yeah see I
appreciate that other people writing has
become such a generic term like of
course yeah stand-up is not something
writing scripts punch-up sure you can
punch it you can do joke right everyone
can write jokes like well there's
there's a lot of people who are like I
know people who listen our vows on
Twitter or like that's [__] funny
joke constantly yeah
but yet
it's not it you are writing in a sense
but you're not a screenwriter name is a
difference it's a dip if it's a
different special you got a really
[__] bullet I mean dude there were so
many dark days there were days where I
would come home from writing and like
you I mean you have to write garbage
forever before you nail that and then
ask where I go I don't know how I would
ever like I was in such a deep dark hole
for four years we used to write like we
didn't know what we were doing we would
write like 20 30 pages reread it back
this sucks erase it all and start
writing again Wow
instead of edit yeah just right there
and we would do that for like that we
once that a script that we couldn't
crack we were walking around his
neighborhood just feeling like what the
[__] yeah we were like what are we
almost we were so lost in it I did you
spent so much time on it yeah I'm
remember like you go this is the only
thing we have right now this is the only
thing that can possibly save us from the
[__] that we're in right now I did say
finally with that script like and it's
just this idea just isn't it well then
you learn like some ideas just don't
work so just yeah it's like audiences
you're not wrong that's the problem you
can't all be wrong yes you go to me
what's the common factor here oh I'm the
one telling the joke every time somebody
else the try exactly if you are the fact
exactly I could ever make this work you
want to give it a go and it's weird
every like professional writer that
we've ever did they've all gone through
the same like if you meet somebody who's
just like oh you're writing is so funny
though so it's almost like I mean there
are you know there are people get
success that you know they're guys who
come right out of film school sell some
but then a lot of times I do run into a
long drought there are savants who are
like just come out and just get it you
know but otherwise you just got to
really learn it but the problem is now
it's like we're at a level where
everything's really good it's just who
is it right for who's looking for
something like this and the window has
gotten smaller we had a work we had a
working screenwriter who years ago we
showed him [__] he goes you guys will be
ill break by 30 I'm not sure if 32
already yeah and like I run into him now
and he's like get in touch with me I'm
like do you every time I do that you
ignore me I mean it is he saying
untouched and
choose to give me your number to get in
touch have you ever had the guy that is
garbage
it's the flaky astruc in city it's like
why are we not making plans right now
yeah you're right we should hang out
well no no hey you wanna hang out on
Tuesday that's what when I said let's go
we should go hiking sometime I was just
expecting I was like I really mean it
but he probably won't ever know no but I
mean we we want if we want a bunch of
place and we want oh yeah loads and
something's like yeah I was like all
right yeah because I didn't sometimes
you go like you know a lot of times you
know a guy from college I ran into out
here and we ran into each other even
though he lives like blocks for me
yeah just like we just you know never
but I wasn't really even we weren't good
friends in college either though but he
guys we run into each other he's like
your number still right number I bet
you've never used it not that hard just
actually text my like hey you wanna have
lunch tomorrow yeah okay you really just
need someone to pull the trick what
person to be like hey yeah let's do it
why is it such a [__] flaky tell is
everyone's so nervous is it is it
because they think someone better might
be available I think it's like like I
don't wanna get rejected I don't know I
think it's like from industry on down
like they set the telling it's hard to
drive anywhere so nobody was there's
that sure it's like yes sure wait how
far do you live yeah it's like if you
this is nearby yeah
Venice yeah sorry can't make it down
there yes it's in general like people
are constantly it's hard to be I love
going you know what I do is I love like
I love going back to the Midwest and you
meet like real people and you're like oh
this is real and they they're not flakes
it's like you want to get together and
have it yeah let's go right now
yeah just anywhere like going on the
road still refreshing here and people
like and I go to New York people like
can I get a drink like sure like come on
but oh no not right like what do you
mean not right now are you have another
spot like no like let's just get the
drink right now like I'm asking for a
big commitment I'm asking for 20 minutes
your time yeah let's have a drink and
then if you want to have another weekend
otherwise just move on and people are
still worried and I was two of like but
maybe they mean to calm down
someone who you're okay with is a bar
next door and there's another bar next
to that just calm down
get a drink and then [__] go maybe
this just people like have anxiety of
like what are we gonna talk about what
are we gonna do I don't know we got to
uh forget it I don't want to go out here
- there's less weirdos in New York you
think that's not well said I mean like
uncomfortable people this town is
literally only exists for industry [__]
yeah it really does
New York exists for other New York seems
felt like a much better up and go city
obviously of the subways you didn't mean
we're here it's like there is way more
planning like is there parking there too
many narcissists that move here that's
my other problem with like not wanting
to live here anymore
is just it's just too filled with too
many [__] [__] were chasing Fame
social climbers who it's like I been at
the store talking to certain people
they'll take off so you another comic
and they literally leave you mitts
you're like wait we were we weren't done
talking look are you doing yeah it's
like they just left you for the hire at
least or that it's sometimes like
sometimes you'll be like oh wait hold on
I have to talk to this person because I
need to talk to them about doing the
show or do it you know what I mean yes
but I'll say it yeah I'll be our back
I'm sorry and I'll apologize it seems
shitty but then it's like I have to it's
like I'm expecting a phone call so when
this comes I gotta take it which
honestly you've turned into somebody
that I didn't think that you would turn
into what duty play well yeah you love
duty now to be on your face and mouth
you like to go you you put duty on his
lip balm earlier you did Duty lips new
animated series Duty lips you become
ultra considerate and like cuz before
you were just a [__] pranker and you
would dude I remember when I broke up
you were a anarchist yeah yeah I
remember when I broke up with my
girlfriend of like 10 years yeah and
then you go you want to do this Road gig
it was you with your wife at the time
and I was like a two-hour drive and the
whole time you're like you know she's
[__] someone else how does that feel
that make you feel good and then I'm
like no she's not and then Ali would be
like she is
and then I was like but you've become
like I altra like yeah like you know 10
years ago you would have thrown that
duty
[__] cloth that was in your ass at me
but this time you were just teasing it I
know I really do think you've become
like a stand-up guy
beep thank you people [__] on me for
like you punch Bobby leader and a so I'm
like and then I made up with him yeah
and then years have passed since that so
I'm like why are you holding its what
was the [__] 20 something-year-old no
I agree but I didn't know that I didn't
know that you would do that in it's a
tough environment by the way by the way
thank you for taking a stand random fan
but like no one at the store ostracized
me it wasn't like people who knew the
players who had more information than
you do people try to get too involved
but at that place there's always turmoil
all those people and now it's changed
because it's way more corporate and like
they all get along and stuff slam when
we were there like we were so put upon
and abused that I would sometimes lash
out at like random people would yeah and
you're like they're like we should
probably blew some opportunities we're
all so [__] upon that it's like you got
to take it out I know like I feel like
even I mean now I'm friends with Edgar
but early on you weren't I was always
[__] with that girl yeah yeah and I
feel bad it's like yeah but I just like
it was in the in that time didn't know
anything it's almost like he took on the
he took on the the attitude of an inert
it's like you're gonna get picked on so
yeah that's what you want everybody fit
into the role yeah perfect I said it too
because if you break up with the girl if
you're the commerce don't you break up
with a girl you just don't tell any more
for six months
you just keep like no things are great
because any mo anyone had on you and
every will try to [__] her and not that
yeah but even if they don't know it's
like you you're still hurting and you're
gonna have guys like saying that you
think she's getting [__] right now
what positions do you think the nine
guys are take putting her in yeah I
don't want it out why whatever happens
you really don't want anyone to know
anything about your personal life at
this yeah Eddie
we even Nashville people still bring it
up hey remember that girl used to date
who's just [__] now
poor you giving you [__] like oh I mean
I still get [__] for some things I know
one thing one thing you got weed brain
right now at about 30 seconds it's all
gonna click I don't think it will feel
quick after we're dotting no you're the
king of giving me the [__] on it someone
you can't really matter dad no oh I know
yeah yeah what's her name I don't know I
know she say I mean I there's no point
the best nice girl yes someone who's
referred to as the as the best sex I've
ever had it was not me but someone has
referred to her that way oh yeah
somebody else maybe on that end yeah
yeah yeah that person P but are you not
shocked at how he's turned out I think I
feel like we're your parents who were
just really shocked that you became a
good person I'm shocked that you like
you levar bald your career you like
spoke it into existence like he did his
son on the laker it's true yeah like
Rena ZZ was like always a you know of
the group was like out in front he was
always gonna work and like whatever but
then Rek made a late push IDI wide it I
was like you know what forget waiting
for them to do it for me yes forget
within the four that somebody else to
say I'm gonna put my name on you they're
not going to it's stupid to keep
thinking they are so I'm like well
should I stop being a comic or should I
like I guess I'll start doing [__] low
level on my own and then eventually like
oh you're doing stuff we'll take you I'm
like okay but then at that point that's
when they made a mistake because now I
don't need them so now I'm like oh look
doing my way though like well we think
this like no I've already been doing it
on my own for a while so you know I'll
listen to you but I'm not gonna do what
you say it's a it's a great power
position but also I'll and I learned
from you you just go yeah I'm gonna do
it I don't I don't need to listen to you
I can do it on my own yeah you can and
it's true they've Smith's just recorded
his own special gas digital was
releasing it how much did it cost
not much
I don't know they got a venue for not
that much in New York's can get like
favors call in people in New York and LA
like have the cameras and have the
know-how yeah
just to find the right people just need
it for one night it's become the
technology's gotten so good that Owen
Smith did the one on the iPhone you know
I mean like there's just a million
different if teen iPhone returns like
are the too many albums now it's [__]
five albums a week not not comedy I mean
music there always have been so and
people still stand out I could say like
I'm gonna say Arcade Fire me and Nick
Youssef we need to use did a show in
Chicago to pay for our trip to see
Arcade Fire just like the show all that
money go to come in LA yeah
every new album coming out but they were
like was it full my kid he sold out with
a Bulls play like what who's that band I
might Arcade Fire I people like I've
never heard of them like and yet it
doesn't matter whether or not you've
heard of them or not so I don't think
there's too many specials coming out
there is one good special coming out to
a week ago that's double negative by Ari
Shaffir that sounds really fun what does
that right now it just came out today
there's it equal one positive double
dagger big silver and what is in this
special children and adulthood
oh that's wonderful yeah two
different-sized can't wait to watch it
you we're an adult outfit and then
dressed like a little sailor boy the
second one or the first like that and
where is the special thanks where we
catch that in the back of childhood and
the back of adulthood oh we're gonna
posit is it yeah David O'Neil or I
separate you guys oh wow thank you no
order to see you separated oh wow wow
goes distance that's how we've lived our
lives Delphis
drawn Horton rhino Neil David Taylor Wow
a very small group very tall men all
over six one yeah very rare in Hollywood
what well five nine beau yeah you ever
but we've been in meetings where way how
tall are you her height does play a
factor will let me hear I'm five nine
you probably what you're like five
eleven probably am 511 lie to your whole
life we've been into meetings where it's
a small a lot of the executives are
small men yeah yeah and you immediately
see that they hate you because like this
one guy literally told us as soon as we
walked in he goes I hate you guys right
now cuz there's like a joke but it you
could tell
obviously it was rude thank you the
place yeah you're like [__] this
meetings the thing about going next time
we're both gonna go in wheelchairs just
chop off our feet for less height dude
you did a great job this wood is
completely burned down this whole time
but he's really OCD about it he loves
playing with those logs because he
pretends it's his duty was write duties
listen to this yeah I told you I told
all you people do you think has anyone
resurfaced from your past that is like
found you like with your notoriety from
high school I got an occasional like oh
man we're so proud of you no not really
high school oh yeah one girl hit me up
for like she was you're big now can you
get me taken out no I'm trying to win
[__] season tickets in the contest
over a decade and that's what you're
coming at me with were you even being
friends
I mean I went to a high school up until
through tenth grade I think 11 that's
why they squish but my fights going had
25 people on did you hook up with her
no who are you out in a farm no just a
small Jewish high school he was in a
Jewish president private hundred people
on the in the high school she no wonder
he didn't [__] till you were later man
sure
but then I switch to another with a
hundred be with anyone [__] that 400
for the high school bad job no nobody's
[__] about that not in my school
there was a couple of people that
frenched what was even like what was the
ratio 12 and 12 or is it 25 mm no no no
is half a girl's hot boys same class
because religiously usually split you up
there for the religious studies they
split us up for that Gomorrah and yeah
and Torah and uh and like Navi and human
class whatever the laws are called oh do
you have gym class in your Jewish school
really I think that was same until would
you grade and then separated what kind
of sport did you play
BBK would spend well baseball kickball
mixture and a marker all in one
yeah mr. marker here we're talking like
this with his hand over his mouth
because he had such horrible breath and
he'd spit he lost his teeth in the war
and uh he would literally because he had
bad breath so uh later what we'll do is
we'll uh yeah he would always come easy
dies you died
everyone loved him just uh just a gym
teacher who didn't really
just the gym teacher didn't molest
that's all you have to do to stand out
in the gym teaching game list feels like
dude I told you that lesbian the work
that we had in my high school made my
sister they made it all the women all
the girls march out of the shower naked
to get towels from her and she would
hand them out to you really yeah she
would hand them out with her teeth yeah
she put them between her tits I mean
definitely borderline behavior but I
don't see a real issue I mean in the 90s
that's just that was this people we're
doing stuff like that back then you'd
have gym teacher to be like make sure
you shower I'm gonna watch oh by the way
did you see Cosby's going out on a tour
teach kids how not to get in trouble and
athletes how to protect yourself from
from accusations yeah that's you should
do that's what the people never do and
obviously you doubled down that he did
it but like he beyond doubled down he's
all in if you think you didn't do it if
that's your stance and if you want to
say like I didn't do it for real then
it's like you wouldn't just be like cool
I'm innocent like wait what the [__]
just happened to me why did 30 people
just say I did this to them or like hey
someone did kill my ex-wife and her love
yeah
can we find that guy yeah he left that
pretty quick the joke was always like oh
I wonder if the guy's a golfer how's the
search going because it's like he's
really looking at a lot of golf course
and spent a lot of time cosby i didn't
go pay to see that tour Oh
$25 I'd heckle we should this whole
thing was like heck of a lot you need to
pay you need to pay these women after
the rape would be what his thing would
be his problem was he didn't pay anybody
off after he raped them I would love to
see what he had to say it would be
insane
I mean they're gonna be jokes did you
guys see him come out of court and give
up they're like yeah Fat Albert he also
could seem to be seeing fine his wife
was with him at all his wife must be
like sweetheart yes we had sex but he
may be sure he knew then he was like
yeah I'm Bill Cosby I think he's like a
beaten dog it was all at their house he
was he such he has manipulated her into
submission
man she is just like whatever bill she's
like a zombie
he lived too long yeah daddy got out
that was the bill burr baton I think
Donald sterling yeah he should have been
dead yeah you get out you're fine but
you live too long for that scandal like
paternity first bit on sterling was
great he was actually pretty progressive
she was like 80 years old he's like
that's a progressive thinking you can
hang out with him you just can't have
sex with him yeah he's dating chicks at
eight block people it goes to my
favorite just I'll put pictures that up
on the Internet yeah that's progressive
thinking hey my girlfriend is dating
some some random athlete give you a
favor on that don't publicize it's a
great bit and then Joe Paterno the same
way Peggy died two years hero two years
earlier here right here and then would
all come out and they'll be like yeah
but this guy's a problem yeah yeah they
[__] they want to lump in everyone
like in reward defending Cosby early on
like Jamie Foxx and stuff like that and
people I [__] you
and it's almost like oh you're making
him a rapist to when all he's doing is
not wanting to believe that is hero
let's hear the you know you're saying
you're telling Jamie Fox that he agrees
that rape should be totally fine does
not he's just like no no this guy was
like a mentor to me I just don't want to
believe it happened yeah the cause my
god that's a crazy when he's so clean
that be like if I found out that a
harsher fear was in the duty play with
ladies and then I would be like now I
don't want to blue I'll never believe in
the duty plays Jim Norton a big duty
player
yeah I think so that's right a man not
gonna say no [__] what what Duty team is
he play for hi the New York duty
knickerbockers stayin knickerbockers New
York [__] streak he's big into I think
people take shits on his chest been
talked about it but that's the
traditional path to take the John McAfee
though is the greatest of all time I did
I tell you about that John the guy who
invented the antivirus software there's
a documentary on Showtime about him
he moves to Belize and he starts having
sex with these teenage girls but it's
not real sex this is the sex that he's
having he is a hammock
say it like you really says a hammock he
says hand lock and keys in it wait how
do you normally say hammock no I say
hammer people on Twitter cuz he's like
it's the Midwest thing ever a lot of it
some people supported me there was a
really depends what area of the Midwest
other guys like yeah I hear him say
hammock go to the Danish inner Neil
podcast on iTunes Leo now on all things
comedy ham right yeah so he had a hole
in it and so the girls would sit over
the hole and his mouth would be open
underneath the hole and they would [__]
into his mouth every time wow-whee and
he would eat it and then a young swallow
he came in and he moved back to the US
after he allegedly may have hired
someone to kill his neighbor down there
and he came in second on the libertarian
presidential on the ballot she almost
got on the presidential ballot for the
libertarian before this election yes
[__] mouth McAfee how scary is this I
mean if you run as a libertarian guy you
must be doing the same thing of just
like I got my name in the paper it's
like you didn't have no hope for winning
I know but you're like your name
everyone that has voted sees your name
on that ticket which is a huge thing
might might my name if I ran for it and
my name is one take it would be Ari
Shaffir appearing at the Minneapolis you
trying to get like some independent does
every second really plan the dates were
we would know whatever your November I
changed my tour to the Midwest Midwest
tour Ari Shaffir the Midwest you do
website to play Ari Shaffir is double-
double dagger now available on Netflix
what if people voted for it and that won
the presidency Oh that'd be great a big
the best press so many people see the
special I would be like what this guy's
algorithm so that if people forget like
it's not just like as simple as like
their meeting you guys just seen it it
blew me away
it's just like I'm a DIY promoter do you
meet on sunset
yeah but um so you know I've like what's
the best like picture we can happen I
was I had like
an artist do a thing for the beginning
of each side an illustrator the guy hand
rendering huh yeah and that's like maybe
I could hire them do another one for
like the main the cover
oh no that's not how we do it like how
do you do it cuz oh and they show me
like so orange the new black
you know how they have like a pictures
of two girls with orange new black yeah
he goes that's only the one you see she
was we have 25 of these and we market
test them in every country so the one in
Germany this one wouldn't test as well
cuz there's a 1.8 seconds before
somebody sees it before they decide to
click or not that's one when it says
that's what I studies have shown and
you're like oh man my other networks I
worked with have never even thought of
stuff like this see there they are they
are beyond ahead of her like what works
on a billboard on sunset on Melrose has
nothing to do with what works in effect
of one inch by one inch like a little
thumb yeah so with like with like Ali
Wong they took her thing her billboard
was her above Seattle as a 50-foot woman
but they're like in a thumbnail that
doesn't register but we did registered
hers sideways so you can see the
pregnant belly holding a microphone well
we know what there's not a movie this is
the stand-up comedy special by a woman
who's brown it's great yeah so anyway so
their algorithm is such that people
start like if if people who start
watching mine have also watched Rogen's
and Segura's after you watch the Gores
mine will come up but more than that
okay if I talk a lot about drugs after
you watch the narcos mine will come up
but here's an even better one here's the
one I was pointing out to these are
their algorithms yeah if for some reason
people are googling you a lot your name
will come up faster oh my first we
actually literally tied into search
engines so I'm like so if I shoot up a
bunch of people and [__] it's in
college somewhere they're like you'll
get a lot more downloads that week you
will be pushed to the front because of a
natural because of a natural like people
interested in New York [__] heat will
go up and then will push you to the
front Wow
it'll just happen not because we decide
but because the algorithm will make that
happen so yeah if you want presidency
you're special get watched a lot so you
have to do something that's not like
heinous but you do need to do something
newsworthy around them like you made the
Doosan like a beauty play video on a
live web or something what you may have
to do like a facebook live duty play
video or something
I could be yeah well you do down your
Instagram like you know people do the
smashing food with their face and stuff
in Korea they do women eat on like men
watch him on the urn when yeah they eat
a ton of [__] like the louder the better
so if you're slow in the noodles yeah
look at that thing go this guy loves
fire you really are a pyromaniac you
watching and watching how says the ism
if we're going to Steve Simone's I don't
need to take a shower cuz I'll just use
that pool cuz I'm on day three of now
yeah bring your bathing suit yeah I'll
bring it you can probably just go now by
the way if you want it I'll just well
I'll probably just like you bring I have
one of those wash ports so just watch my
clothes if you're listening to this
podcast you too can go to Steve Simone's
if you have a time machine
how many also if you if you our
listeners podcasts listen to the day mr.
Neale podcast by the way it has one of
the highest retention rates in the
podcast it's not laughable dude
undisputed champ and check out our new
show they're trying to get going called
knockers it's about door-to-door
satellite to tell the television sales
it's great what is that what is it on oh
you just go to our Facebook page
knockers finished Facebook page no
knockers is the Facebook page do this
career it's based on these real guys
this is a real thing it's crazy
every summer these dudes they're like
all in they're like young 20s yeah they
descend upon like mainly the Midwest and
the south and they sell door-to-door or
satellite cable and there's some of
these guys are making upwards of like a
hundred grand a summer some of these
managers in the summer they're like 21
they're make 250 some guy was making 430
at all because they're 21 so due to
driving new Porsches and boats but you
get locked into the life so they have to
go back and keep doing the next summer
yeah Wow and so they go to the town they
raise hell all they do there's easy they
sell satellite dishes yeah just go door
to door selling satellite like we can
lower who are you with now they've all
these techniques to get inst inside they
have all these techniques to try to they
don't rob you they just sell you should
just sell me one guy I'm gonna lower
your bill the one guy was so good there
was a no soliciting sign he took it off
a house sold
to a neighbor who was pissed that he was
there so what that no soliciting nein he
came to their door like no so like what
the hell
oh I have a sign you want to buy it off
me yeah sold it to him
like we were pissed at him Wow and this
guy's like oh let me sell that it's a
fascinating world then yeah oh yeah we
didn't know existed and talking we got
immersed ourselves in it we also went
out there to go sell with them looking
yeah you have to man re we're pros man i
dude if court you probably did some
research for shooter you played
basketball right come to the live show
October 2017 at the Bell House in New
York sell me the bellows I got a read
all of shooters this is a picture or
should I not maybe I'm not going to the
whole thing I started reading it and
then I feel good that you're like a
Viking I was like episode that we talk
about shooter I don't remember I think
we've talked about it a few times all I
remember you gotta get some big-name
guys I mean I don't know you almost want
like something maybe I think you're old
I think you're too old for the character
I think you should maybe play the coach
they look at Pete Davidson a place
shooter yeah young kid yeah hey you
baller do too man donuts and soda about
about Pete Davidson yeah you get louis
c.k to play something he would probably
if you settle the script he was like yes
I'll play somebody all just placeholders
who's gonna play he man dude you know
what you should do maybe Shantae black
Dante oh I feel big just saw him on uh
who's black Dante okay there's a lot of
ring any other huge oh yeah I did a bit
where he speaks Hebrew you know what
would be a funny series would be like
well-known writers bring their very
first script that they ever wrote for
readings like you great light show that
like brings something that we can read
but to have like a looking for all the
poetry i read natasha you thought it
would win her back or i win her back was
right we broke up and like this is my
last chance
i've got it doesn't have that and she oh
wait did she see had she seen the poetry
before and you just still i mailed it to
her it was every other day or every
other three days i would send her a
letter either a letter saying why should
take me back and the next one three days
later a poem and the prettiest later
here's a game boys take me back and then
again poem to have physical copies of
things to ask like begging someone it's
there's nothing worse i like yeah I've
done that i have like a million emails
where it's like I'm a [__] idiot
please I need you know what do you think
that she heard Moshe have those like on
their refrigerator and everyday they or
box somewhere I can see it being like a
coffee table book that you make under
glass yeah you can look at it's like oh
by the way that what you're seeing here
is are your fears poems that it's like
tables at Barney's Beanery yeah why
don't she still has that you think she
does do you talk to her at all I see her
that way I don't know man I could see
having a box of mementos memento why
would you keep also why would you throw
something that's pure gold like that
away you don't I made to like true later
in life to need it against him yeah yeah
so you're mailing them you weren't just
mailing emailing would have been a lot
easier maybe they never got though you
want to mail that you want a hand letter
that would you do they special paper I
think I did like what did you use like
bone canary canary yeah did you like
calligraphy I don't have it did you hire
a calligraphy to transcribe your poetry
did you put a cent on there like rub
your small sweat yeah you know maybe
that's what idea you know what you
should have written it in doobie I
needed you guys back then were you
around when I was dating etosha yeah you
were I remember we were like open mic
thing and you you'd be coaching her in
comedy in the corner yeah teach her how
to do crowd work really and you would
host and she'd come in with you and it
was like here's and we were always like
what is she
with this guy I mean even now and even
then there's no disagreement with that I
have no idea what she'll be doing with
me
she was so much hotter than me unless
you're so into Jews which I guess she
was she was yes it was but Duncan isn't
but he [__] is but he looks like yeah
he seems like he could be yeah like like
like Mike Young is is a Jew but like
that's not the type she'd be into ya
know once like whoa what are those guys
oh yeah evidently that is the goat
that's her move but yeah she was she
still is a very pretty young lady then
back then she was wearing Jesus wasn't
she wearing gloves on stage back then no
no she started doing that later no she
still she had that persona of the gloves
still why I had the attitude that that
like debutante attitude yeah that was
like her personal merit or because
unless you say the horrible things that
you actually really feel sometimes here
a while fer to hone it and not be
unlikable yeah and to get to the point
where it's like it's sort of a character
but also sort of not back then it was
like all character or no character yeah
she got it that's what you do with you
develop your your skills up she's funny
she's she's in everything like I'll see
she plays great drunk does voiceover
he's like a bat a great like [__] wife
like oh yeah that's funny
uh-huh it was so frustrating trying to
break up with her and then like singer
on like Aqua Teen Hunger Force like I
know that voice
god dammit get out of my apartment you
write a letter a poem here's a poem that
about the appearance on Aqua Teen Hunger
Force the best character by far an Aqua
Teen Hunger Force is Carl the neighbor
yeah I could help but notice that you
guys are my pool with blood smell this
rotting carcasses in my yard you keep
that do you remember when he would he
bought when they got a mail-order bride
him it was a head shake him and shake
ordered a woman and the thing but they
were trying to sign how to split it like
he's like Pedro is one of the best
episodes
Carl there's such a funny [__]
was either hit or miss they were either
brilliant or it was like I think so yeah
but not new one are there new ones
aquitine is great good crazy oh and I
love that's one of my dreams to get on
that Squidbillies something I mean maybe
just in New York Jew wait did you say
adults who have animated show would be
your dream because we might have the
pitch for you oh yeah what happen with
that and we'll tell you when we're done
okay let's pitch it on air and then say
wish you guys could be working writers I
mean we we have enough money to be like
y'all just bought it's time for a new
car got a new one nothing crazy which is
something I can eat whatever I want
yeah I mean now I can but I have to make
sure it I can only eat whenever I want
as long as it's made at home right and
now it's like we you need enough like
we'll get like we're getting stuff but
it's just like you need root eat you
know like you need to get over the hump
or you're like now I've got money to
turn [__] down like now we get and you
could be free and like explore like now
we do a project like we wrote we got we
wrote knockers for this production
company yeah and like so that was enough
money to let you know but then like you
just cut like it's not enough to so now
we have like a movie in the pipeline but
then it's like that'll get us you just
need that like you need the ball to
start rolling down the hill the whole
time yeah instead of rolling and then it
hits another up hill and you got to push
it up that hill everyone roll yeah oh
wait if it broke my foot because it
rolled on it was this now yeah yeah now
I don't have to hi know who flew to
Icarus Icarus and they didn't have a
cookie puss is Tommy Morris's favorite
cake at Carvel eyes yeah cookie puss and
she caught if he called him cookie cuz
she thought he was a woman for a while
well Mets he thinks I'm a woman okay a
handsome woman did you listen to him on
our all Skakel's fun was it great he bad
he goes Wow felt bad I should have given
him better spots and then it was like
what so why didn't you Wow we got a
charge against Bob just you know
couldn't do it never say like I don't
know man I was I mean I was wrong I got
locked in my head of like that I'm not
giving spots
looking back they were great I should
have done I was gonna sponsor way worse
people he was it's really funny though
how like you bow your head up yeah gecko
dude throw it in the fire if we had
gotten better spots on the bricks don't
throw it in the fire let it be to the
left of that black face it yeah that's
the crazy thing is like if we had gotten
better spots things definitely like
people will be like whoa or whatever
maybe you could have gone other places
but to have a club where you can
actually develop with real crowds is
very difficult to find in LA and like it
definitely would have changed our total
trajectory and also no one really once
you get past the store no one really
leaves it to go look for better spots
obviously you should at some point do
more and other things you only tripoli
ever because he was already doing like
two spots a night before he got to the
store went out and branched out really
yeah everybody else like no if I get
spots y'all do them for not yeah it
won't use get comfortable and get
comfortable you know everyone you know
the room it's such a hustle though too
for doing other stuff if you know how
everything works takes all day TIFF
hustled out other spots yeah it does in
LA just call in and come in I saw your
picture on the Laugh Factory marquee oh
yeah I don't like the digital marquees
no no like the old-school yeah that's
gross it's hard to live happy mark you
they put it up there even if you're
there that month but I remember ever
being able to look at the whole marquee
take it in now it's like if you have the
light you're like all right so one looks
like it's in a [__] mall it does it's
tacky like [__]
a digital mark he looks like it just
looks improv one with it to implement
digital market yeah because of all the
money that I'm not making now Jesus
who's making money hand over fist is
like that's make a guy climb a [__]
lab everybody like comedies back now
Mike gold look at the [__] improv on a
Thursday and see if comedies back is it
really just I mean dude I mean the store
owes Rogan Marin and Diaz you pretty
much everybody who has a podcast came up
through the store that tell old stories
of the store so then people go like up
his must be awesome and now it's a
little lamer because you have these
[__] fans that come out and you just
want to like do drugs with your friends
and then it's like hey Kyle take a
picture it's like oh man even the VIP
bar I walk in there I go I don't know a
single person in here these aren't the
comics that this was this was meant to
like get away because there had been so
any people that now not even just I'm
not talking about like fans most of the
people that I've run-ins who have been
super respectful but it's just like
there's too many hanger honors who come
there every night sort of thing yeah who
like just go there to booze and get
wasted and like like what's the cause of
seams writer like he'll be back there's
like what yeah here what's what why a
kitchen has become unholy you know it's
like it used to be like mad only yeah
like that's where you would go to escape
but now it's like why is this random
like nowhere you can go to actually
escape escape it used to be multiple
places here you go Oh a lot it has to be
alone
now you can't yeah quiet spots maybe run
over your bits real quick before you go
up I was like twigs I can't no I've told
somebody I'm about to go I'm about to go
on let me and then they go okay and they
keep talking like no no I'm like it
literally it's in a minute I need a con
straight like okay I just tell you this
one thing I'm like dude please I know
I literally at the wall I have to walk I
have to roam before I go up because
people will stop yeah but like hey I'm
next I'll talk to you after this and
then they just keep it's just it doesn't
go on you know a new word I stood I'm in
the cage which many was on deck and you
leave them alone but it's like I've
tried talking to people about like
either like you know what maybe we were
talking on something and like and you
just can't do it there yeah cuz I people
later rob people cut you're like I can't
talk to you so many feel button what are
you guys talking about what is it I'll
just offer their stick and you're like
alright yeah as you're talking have it
conversation because of biases even the
other comments okay how you doing like
okay how you doing you know like I kind
of want to get back to the conversation
I know I haven't seen you but I'm in the
middle of it
yeah dialogue sit quietly and listen I
guess the only good interruption we ever
had was when we and you were talking
it's telling I didn't really Sean Patton
was in LA yeah well he went when he we
saw him that this is not happening and
he was asking about boom Shakalaka yeah
remember the time you were talking in
the parking lot and like I think you
scratched like your chest or your balls
or something and he just like appeared I
don't know where to scratch that itch
[Laughter]
under scratch that is like that old
pedophile and Family Guy
yeah scratch that is me but it was just
like oh we were being watched
like we were just talking like scratch
that itch I didn't know Sean Patton he
was in LA for like a year or two okay
for a little bit vaguely I kind of
remember him at the store like maybe
doing something over there open mic or
something
it was really good I'm a guy who likes
getting like a little bit of everyone's
camp right exactly
yeah he's training all over oh well so
we got to talk about I feel like it's
time to rap like we yeah what do you
think about the state of the UFC right
now bad news well William Moore is
taking over and it's like oh now it's
like the corporate thing and they have
these remnants and you still want to
believe it was the way it was four years
ago but it's not that but it still looks
like it so you're still left thinking oh
it should be this
just like the we talked about Hollywood
like though it's about merit right
you're like somewhat but mostly not know
that networking is a big thing and so
you look at it like oh the way they ban
people for weed the the punishments they
have are so severe the strip that all
the [__] double interim title shots
cuz like it does better if we have a
title versus the title well not to
mention McGregor if he leaves after this
mayweather fight you have two weight
classes that don't have a real champion
because he wouldn't defend them and to
let him just run free and take two belts
and hold them hostage
never mind dana put his job of running
the UFC on hold to book a fight that has
nothing to do everybody put on hold I'm
sure he's still looking for it no I know
but it was like he was just so into that
it's like you're putting your eggs in a
basket where he is gonna go why would he
fight again for way less also you have
Cormier is not the real champion at 205
you eat three divisions with not real
champion there's no real champion 55
there's no real champion at 45 and now
you have GSP left but he's been gone
enough time do you have a real champion
at 70 yes right now the Alpha he sort of
got defeated when he went he before
there's lots he lost never really
thought was the champ the women's
division was ya know yeah that one girl
you want to join a vine the only really
one that's like the real champ
no no Mighty Mouse but he doesn't get
promote but now TJ now they're throwing
TJ Dillashaw a down there not even a
weight class he's ever fought at and
then and also now you had
Bisbing not even fighting a real 85 guy
for a title z fighter well they keep
pushing the GSP thing oh yeah I wanted
to fight
Romero but business like nah man Jerry
wants to wait there was a way for cuz he
knows that's a huge payday GSP I mean
Romero is heavy mother and I get it you
can't fault these guys but the end time
it is admission Amer I'm done if I lose
the GSP I'm done but like I'll get paid
way better chance of beating GSP yeah
and I'll get paid even if I lose both I
get paid way more for losing GSP than I
do for Romero McGregor do you know then
I get one then I still have Romero it's
not about belts it's all about money
fighters they never work ideas they
never worked it yeah it wasn't was about
who's most deserving so I had a long
time like why is that gonna get a title
shot like what's his name Chael Sonnen
like why would he get a teller said he's
never fought it 205 yeah and then it's
like they talked up a game and it's like
yeah but he's giving people that are
actually deserving he his old thing was
and it's a lot of businesses that he's
like boxing they don't make the fight
people want to see and that's what he's
turned into oh good shot it's just sad
it's sad what is happening because you
just got guys what did the days of Chuck
Liddell being like I'll fight anybody I
don't give a [__] or Donnell it's over
between the realest guys don't exist
WME the way they treated goldberg on his
way out
yeah didn't even mention it yeah it's
like and now he's in Bellator which is
the best slap in the face of the UFC
gold the ballot or dude also the dynamic
of Rogan Dominick Cruz and Cory a does
not work at all because nobody's doing
the [__] yeah that what Jesus would
Goldberg did which was like set it up I
think they think Rogen's gonna leave so
they want Cormier to learn on the job
maybe but you need Rogan to play off a
guy like Goldberg was like and he would
spew out facts that didn't exist yeah
oh he did and he turned gave him the
finger you did what oh yes y'all fast
and also be like yeah we wanna get so so
drug levity too now it's just all those
serious a little bit sometimes yeah I
guess I didn't know that I loved what he
would say something Rogan would go
completely against it
talking about yeah what are you talking
about all right
all right let's wrap this up how long
has done what how long have we done six
I think is it any good yeah 3:06 man
we're done people want it okay so listen
to the Danish and O'Neill podcast you
can find it we're all podcasts are on
iTunes SoundCloud on the all things
comedy website laughable it's actually a
great and last yeah I love it it's great
we interact with that dude all the time
he's [__] he's a big supporter net
from laughing great dude yeah he's great
but it really is like so if you listen
this right now if you're on laughable
you can just danish it on Neil yeah
button will be right at the bottom
don't even stop just click subscribe and
then listen to the end of like without
stopping this
get right into it yeah you can see your
website right there as you're searching
ever do a show across the board that
whitter that thing is going to be huge
when it finally takes hold it's only on
iPhones now which is a little bit of
well I'm trying to get right into
Android yeah they're trying to get
Android now but like in the meantime
most people have iPhone so let's just
it's great free also yeah and you can
also literally see all the podcasts that
we've been on oh there's that too so if
you're like hey already didn't do an
episode this week you're just gonna re
Shaffir and you go here's a bunch yeah
you guys are great guests you can see
the Kreischer episodes
we're on crisis were on the energy which
show we go on get on Rogen's podcast
because it's a great honor I know I
would love to I would love to like we've
never even like officially met him oh
really mean like we've just always been
with him or if we try to like interview
you into something you know what I think
though what you guys but he loves
hunting he loves cars he loves like we
all love MMA we you know I think we'd
have a ton to talk about yeah I think
we'd have some differing opinions on
something crazy to go crazy
do the Dino stuff you know I don't know
but either way it would be nice to find
out a move
what if he attacks do you think I was
trying to hit it threw that at him the
way you should we should we should glue
a horn on to his head it's good idea and
turn him into a machine species like a
war machine
we went on the you like we went on this
retreat seeing you see we had seen you
weak and we went to like somehow like we
went to like I think New York like for
our [__] ride but like see left it
like 4:00 in the morning in like from
Boston yeah 20 minutes outside in a
buddy of mine like smuggled weed but
they like they were like super hardcore
about it years later they brought in
dogs and I caught people [__]
bringing weed really yeah so he brought
in weed we smoked like deep in the woods
of this fights I think it's called like
Eastover or something they like a little
resort in the middle of nowhere yeah I
need a buffalo behind like [__] shitty
mesh fence and we were like we were up
we were high Buffalo and we were
throwing like small rocks buddy directly
up the [__] skull made the most
lasting sound bow down bow the thing
just slowly slowly coming out of your
bubbles like Louise [__] idiot Wow
the fence was like chicken we don't move
thinner you don't need much to keep them
in but all I have to do is when they
realize that they can get through if
there's like a stampede they'll run
through anything there's nothing you can
stop and I think that rock was a a wake
up call
yeah we're slaves yeah dude you grew up
in Boston right 20 minutes how so Simone
as you know it takes care of those like
Children Hospital kids yeah cuz I'm
spends time with him and stuff do you
know this oh yeah yeah yeah I heard
about it he posted some kids oh right
the Buddhists the town it's some kid he
was like you know with the with the no
hair from chemo yeah and like some tubes
in his arms he's running a Red Sox hat
and a Red Sox shirt and he goes you know
prayers for my friend Tom you know my
friend Timmy he's battling real hard
right now and he loves the Red Sox and
and it's his dream to I don't know meet
Tony so David Ortiz he put that on
Instagram and then my comment was [__]
the Red Sox and this lady was like I
think there's bigger things at stake
here than your sports teams that man is
a sick boy
if i had to sum up one thing like you
had to explain to Ari Shaffir somebody I
would just show up that because this
explains him 100% hey right here I've
never seen you don't represent something
that sums you know more than that
[__] sweet all right let's get why
yeah why look up knockers on Facebook
we'll put a link to it on our Twitter I
put a link to it for on my website are
either great calm or I put up extra dude
he went under the fence I put up extra
details every week and show the music
stuff you ever want to know the music
stuff Ari the great calm Ari Shaffir
calm same [__] and I'll put a link to
knockers
yeah anything else you guys guys get
real jobs somebody hire these people to
be actual writers on show well we're
moving our movie we have something that
will hopefully where we can come to your
Opik we've pitched this before and he
asks people you don't like oh really
yeah very good
we don't know how well that's gonna pay
off do a lot of traveling just come to
your office how much could you possibly
charge for that well maybe we'll do an
app where we can wants to wipe my butt
and put in your fist okay
the Sakura
all right yeah what a long episode but
there's something I was gonna say in the
out show I forgot what the [__] what
and that publisher says I stole a book
advantage Dropkick Murphys show for the
outro yeah I don't know I don't know
don't forget by the way well don't
forget I should just tell you if you're
gonna go shopping for your schoolbooks
and stuff on Amazon can you please use
my Amazon link it's right on my website
or at the great calm there's one for
Amazon there's one for amazon.ca for
Canada I know you got a lot of book
shopping to do so you got to do it
anyway so just click on that button
it'll take you in to Amazon and then do
your all shopping as normal and then and
then I get a percentage of your sales or
whatever they just send me a check for
like some some money it's a helps
[__] support the podcast so it'd be
cool if you could I would appreciate it
and I'd a sponsoring a why I keep
turning them down yeah you know I turn
down the shitty ones the ones that
aren't [__] good I'm not going to
tell you guys that [__] get some
shitty product good products I'll tell
you to get shitty products uh-uh
check out Danish no Neil I put up
pictures I put up a picture of us at
[__] where dropkicks was on stage
with us with our wristbands with some
other dude just he just thought were
just showing wristbands and he put it in
his wristband so you could see the
difference between our [__] shitty
wet-nap wristbands with gum on it you
can really see on Chris's hey I'm a
[__] the gum you really see it look
at that what we should have done
oh this what we should have done so once
we're in we're like let's not leave but
they were like we're gonna have to pee
and we were gonna have to pay so what
are we gonna do piss Cup we figured out
a way to do it where you stand in the
circle everyone's looking at each other
up against the back wall there's a side
wall where no one could play behind you
and you just all talk looking up at each
other's faces one guy's guy's dick out
in a cup pissing
then you take the cup and you put it in
the trash can so we should have done we
should have pissed cupped it took a
major chance not doing that didn't get
let back in one way went around I didn't
get lapped back on the other way they
will actually come out like no you stay
in there I come on back around the first
way nailed it
heavy motion I was [__] to two or
three people back when the lead singer
ran sir was he like on the crowd [__]
holding his mic into the crowd were
yelling Ruby Soho sweating what a great
time I mean you just fall you just let
yourself move backwards a little bit and
now you're in the pit just circle and
everyone smile somebody's [__]
sneaker would hit your head is there
crowd surfing over there man what a fun
time what a fun time so that's the
episode Thank You Danish Geoff dannis
and O'Neill Ryan O'Neal for coming in
and doing it those guys are always great
350 I might let him interview me about
my travels 450 but that won't be for a
year and I'll be I'll be in Scotland
this time next year I'll be in Scotland
another pick by the way for the Fringe
you want to check out Sean Patton for
sure another pick that i mentioned
before re l jarn from Iceland from
Reykjavik he's there for the first time
check his show out and then all the
records I'll hear Shaw Alex Smith Alice
Keely male roommates Carl Donnelly who's
been on this podcast Peter Hanson who's
been on this podcast I think he has
who's not happening
don't forget to get tickets make your
plans find friends for September Los
Angeles September 13th in the main room
I'm not gonna tell you lineup I will
tell you it's gonna be good I mean I
want to start working on it yet I just
booked it today the room so it's gonna
be good and all the money for that show
$20 the UCB has a policy where they
charge the upright citizens brigade as a
policy where they will not pay comedians
so they
charge a cover charge they take that
money and they give them none of it to
comedians people have asked them like
well why don't you pay comedians and
said we can't afford to I'm like okay
and they go why don't you raise your
tickets
ten bucks and then split up the five
between the comedians and take the fight
for yourself same price they go no we
won't
their policy as comedians should not be
paid I disagree with that wholeheartedly
I don't think most people know that when
they go to UCB show that literally zero
the money goes to the UCB and all the
money goes to Amy Poehler and her
friends in fact in one show and asked at
there was a story of Amy Poehler passing
around a hat saying hey guys if you
could like give money that's how we
should keep the show going Amy Poehler
this didn't back then this is after
Parks and Rec started Amy Poehler's
passing around a hat to pay for the UCB
well the comedians make zero dollars
it's great that's great business model I
really don't agree with it in any way
I think it's shitty I think it shows a
lack of respect for stand-up comedians
Sarah Silverman once we were talking
about and she goes well you know I got
to pay for a valet parking and that used
to be on Franklin at least behind me my
valet please keep me [__] seven
dollars to pay my valet no Sarah
Silverman
you're not worth valet money according
to the UCB you are not worth valet money
they go well you're lucky to perform
here I go well yeah maybe I mean I'm
lucky to get on any stage but UCB aren't
you lucky to get Sarah Silverman to
perform there aren't you lucky to get
Galifianakis to perform there top level
comedians it's a two-way street
anytime somebody claims loyalty or
[__] you're lucky for this like
alright let's really look at it though
so they don't pay anybody I think it's
[__] and they say well we can't
afford to stay open like that and then
with their current policy they opened up
a second location that one on Franklin
and then they open up a third location a
second location in New York now they
have three stores and now they open up a
fourth location a second one in Los
Angeles so they're expanding they're
paying comics is $0 charging money to
come see those comics paying them $0 and
expanding I don't see how you justify
paying that so
all my shows are different my shows I go
the opposite way I believe what's fair
is that half the money that you bring in
for a show after costs just show costs
not paying your rent to paying bills and
I think that but so I can restore it
we're not counting up the cross calm
restored the [__] booze sales pays
for the waitresses booze sales pace with
the door guys so they don't have costs I
mean cost like if you've got to rent out
a theater so sure pay the theater and
then what's left over half that money
goes to the promoter that's fair that's
plenty you're not no one's coming to see
you promoter but you do a service you
start up the whole show the other half
gets split up to the comedian's the
Comedy Store does that and their main
room shows on Fridays and Saturdays
where they split it up that's their own
shows not the privately book shows like
this is not like she's my or his rhenium
storytelling show that I'm doing and the
other half goes the comedian's they
split that up and that's fair that is
what I would expect the minimum to be
that's not what I do for myself because
I'm a comedian and I don't want to be
making money as a promoter off comedians
I'll make money in other ways I'll start
up a show I make it big enough and get
on television so then I make money as a
producer sure I figure out other ways to
make money I make money and live sales
in my own I'm here to make great shows
for you guys and my money gets split up
this way every comic takes an equal
percentage of all the money 100 percent
of the door money gets split up to the
comedians that's how I do it and people
say you don't have to do that Mike hmm
well the other option is me taking money
that I could do that I could just say
hey here's 200 bucks more than anybody
gets paid on a [__] Monday night but
I don't do that that's not the way I
want to do it for myself so this is if
the UC pays pay zero and that's way too
little I'm paying all and maybe that's
too much by the way I still get my cut
if there's five if I'm hosting there's
five comics I get one six
I'm not taking zero I'm taking one six
so come to this September 13th anti UCB
show it's called back to school is the
topic for the stories it's all stories
about education schooling in any way I'm
not gonna tell you lineup you will be
surprised by every single comedian on
there
this show will sell out because that's
what happens with great shows people get
the word and they'll sell out so get
your tickets start making plans get
tickets and know that all the kimete all
the money goes towards supporting
comedians UCB [__] yourselves ladies and
gentlemen thank you very much for tuning
in there's been already for your skeptic
tank for Danish attorney Island
definitely check out the podcast Danish
and O'Neill on iTunes now on the
laughable app for sure you should check
them out they're funny and everything
they do I'm Ari Shaffir saying so long
for episode 300 Quinton time to get what
I mean why couldn't take my [__] yeah he
gets so worried when I sit in the woods
he was like couldn't believe it you know
things I've done you guys when I was
traveling I put myself in horrible
situations I'll press out again but I
ain't pressed out yet like 300 over so
we called it quits
cool
quit wave Harlequin it sounds like the
easy way out but Oh will it be the
longer you live with someone you can't
live with the harder it is we call the
magic then we call the tragic finally we
called it quits it's always been harder
to fall out of love and fall here
I don't know where I'm doing but I doubt
if I'll ever forget where I've been we
couldn't call it happy though it was for
a while we couldn't call it sad cuz it
taught us forward to smile for lack of a
better word Dakota we called it quits
[Applause]
we
quit we called it quits
it sounds like the easy way out but Oh
with you longer you live with someone
you live with the harder it is
we called it lovely then we called it
lonely finally we called it quits
[Music]
we called it magic then we called it
tragic finally we called it quits